canada is suspending the rollout
of one of the vaccines i don't know
which one uh over
fears about blood clots so we're gonna
get into this specifics on that story i
wanna be very careful with this because
you know we wanna make sure we're
getting this data these stories accurate
but
in the bigger picture the reason this is
important is that the biden
administration
is reportedly planning a rollout of a
national coveted
vaccine passport or just a general
vaccine passport i guess
because i'm willing to bet this app is
going to include all of the vaccinations
you've gotten
not just covet we'll see in new york
they
already have this and a lot of people
are angry rightly so because
even cnn compared it to be to to
nazis demanding you show your papers no
joke fareed actually showed a scene
where a guy was like give me your papers
and then he is like i don't have them
and then the cops are coming or whatever
that's pretty intense when even cnn is
bringing up that argument but they have
this ethical dilemma about
whether or not vaccine passports are
legit and so we're going to get into
all of the deep philosophical and
ethical questions around this
and i think it's fair to say when you've
got countries that are you know issuing
issuing these warnings
when people with food allergies aren't
supposed to get it when pregnant women
aren't supposed to get it
how are you gonna roll out mandatory
vaccines when you're also telling people
why they shouldn't get it or certain
countries are putting in restrictions
that seems absolutely just just nuts to
me but we'll get into all this
we've got some other stories there's a
school apparently it's in virginia right
yeah
where apparently these teachers are
getting doxxed because they oppose
critical race theory
and it's people in the school who are or
it's
it's a crazy story i mean the level of
indoctrination from critical race theory
is just getting nuts
even sesame street now is coming out
right against
martin luther king jr's vision which is
kind of shocking to me so
we'll get into it joining us today of
course is cassandra fairbanks
hey thank you for having me quick intro
just maybe you know a few seconds
i write for gateway pundit um irritate
people on twitter constantly
i don't know that's about it there you
go we got you and chillin what's up
everybody ian crossland over here
good to see you in the corner pushing
buttons we have a great night tonight
that's right and we have an amazing
sponsor tonight everybody let's give a
shout out to
pocketnet.app in the description below
you will see the link to pocketnet
a fully decentralized social media
platform they say
no corporation open source nobody can
take your subscribers away
all advertising revenue goes directly to
you as
content creator it is owned and
self-policed by users like you
and these are all really really smart
things one of the coolest things about
this they mention
that it is it is totally decentralized
there's no central authority or
corporation
the platform is run by equal nodes on a
blockchain all revenue is split between
node operators and content creators
node operators stake pocketcoin in order
to mint blocks with rewards
and transaction fees half of rewards in
each block go to content creators based
on
ratings their content gathers from users
the reason why i'm stoked to have
pocketnet as a sponsor is because we've
often talked about the need for
decentralizing social media
it's one of the things we really want to
implement too with timcast.com
we want to incorporate some way that
there can be a decentralized ability for
individuals to comment speak their minds
have their opinions
and no one can ban them i think the the
reality of social media is that
you need to put the individuals in
control of what they see
now twitter does this you can block
people but for some reason there's an
obsession with manipulating and
controlling that flow of information
probably in my opinion for political
game with a system like pocket net
totally decentralized
there is no boss there's no one who
could take that power
so it's pretty cool so special shout out
and thank you to pocket for sponsoring
the show their link is in the
description below
you can go to pocketnet.app and check it
out and also don't forget
go to timcast.com and become a member to
get access to exclusive members only
segments where we talk with our guests
about a bunch of
you know things youtube usually doesn't
want us to or sometimes we just kind of
weird with it we talk about like dmt and
god
and uh recently we had jeremy uh from
the quartering
we had aaron berg we had jody shaw we
had kurt schlichter jack murphy
comedian chrissy mayer so make sure you
go to teamcast.com become a member
because this is how you support the show
and we're going to be rolling out a ton
of amazing new content
i'm actually planning on hiring a news
editor we're going to be hiring some
writers we're going to start making
articles
and we're even thinking about doing tv
shows movies short films and just
going absolutely nuts with it so again
go to timcast.com become a member
and i also want to give a a quick
mention for people who are curious about
the specifics
on what happened with friday's show and
being canceled and there's no big
conspiracy there's no big controversy
quite literally there was some
miscommunication we had jeremy from the
quartering love him he's an awesome dude
we were gonna have him on for two nights
in a row but i guess at some point
someone gave him the wrong time to show
up
and because we had already done a show
with him we kind of like
exhaust a lot of what we want to talk
about a lot of ideas we needed to do
pre-production
and i guess jeremy was given the wrong
time so that's totally on us we were the
ones who told them where and when
to be to be up here and be ready to go
and then by the time we were getting set
up to go we had like only a few minutes
to actually launch and i was like dude i
just
i i don't want to launch a show and be
like we don't know what we're doing we
don't know we're talking about so maybe
it just doesn't make sense
and it's our fault and so i want to
apologize to jeremy for for
you know that happening it's totally our
fault that's all i can really say about
it
but let's uh let's jump into the first
story about fox
uh i'm sorry the bide administration
working with it's from fox business the
bite administration working with
industry to develop covet 19 passports
as vaccinations
progress passports offer a glimpse of a
future that
many are longing for after months of
covet 19 restrictions i really love that
fox is saying that
people are longing for vaccine passports
aren't aren't you guys because
kanji ian don't you want to be able to
have an app where they can know
everything about you and you scan it if
you want to go shopping
i'm really bummed that it's an app and
not paper makes things a lot more
difficult show me your papers
no they're saying it it will also be
paper oh okay
i think coveted passports okay hold on
let me take the social credit score in
china
right well so they implemented a similar
system i'll just break it down very
simply for for those that don't know
what it is
you will have an app on your phone you
will put in all your private information
and then when you get vaccinated it will
have that information if you go to the
store or you go to a theater or you go
to an airline
they'll have an app but you must scan it
to prove you've gotten your vaccinations
i think covet is just the beginning how
long until they're like
oh if you want to go to the store have
you gotten you know your hep shot or
something like that or your tetanus shot
have you gotten your flu shot well you
got to have that and with the ease of an
app like this the vaccine passport
they're calling it
then you know walmart or whoever else
can be like you know what everybody
should get flu shots end of story
so you better carry around your papers
right yeah i don't i don't have a phone
i don't carry paperwork around with me
get off my back
i'm just wondering how long it's going
to take for a black market for
for them to spring up on it you know
fake
yeah i feel like people are gonna have
hacked apps like you're gonna
people are just gonna jailbreak their
phones and make their own apps medical
tracking is terrifying i mean if they
make it so you can't do anything without
it people are gonna find a way to get it
even if they don't actually want to get
the vaccine or if they can't
think about how crazy that's going to be
though like you can't go to walmart
unless you have an app you can scan on
the way in
so what about somebody who doesn't own a
phone right let's say you're really
really poor
you can't even get any kind of
smartphone even though there's some
pretty cheap ones you can't get it
and then whether you got to go you got
to go to a place to issue a vaccine
passport from a certain place on a card
they say that voter id is racist because
poor people and minorities
struggle to go to the dmv and i'm like
dude the dmv has been around for
literally ever
everybody can ask someone oh it's a dmv
yet if you if you if you went
outside right now and walked up to a
random person and said hey where can i
get a vaccine they're like i don't know
so you think poor people and these
people you believe are underprivileged
are gonna have an easy time
figuring out how to navigate the system
nah they're creating some kind of like
caste system this is like when polio the
vaccine can people wanted that vaccine
because polio's crippling people was
terrifying as deadly as devastating
so people wanted it you didn't have to
force them to get it and
and track to make sure they got it like
people were just getting it because they
needed it they wanted it
this vaccine that thing has a 99.97
percent recovery rate
this this covet thing i don't think a
vaccine is necessary especially ones
that are
accessing blood clots for older people
maybe for older people yeah maybe
but it's still so early in the process
that they rushed it out in like a year
six months this vaccine's been out i'm
not i'm not super opposed to the rushing
process
i'm i'm concerned about the non-approval
process you know what i mean
as well yeah so the fda hasn't approved
this yet yeah both of those things
concern me
i think that the rush is is scary i mean
we don't know what the lasting effects
of any of this stuff will be we don't
even know what the lasting effects of
covid will be
so just all of it the rush
the lack of you know testing and
approval i
i just it freaks me out and i'm i'm very
pro vaccines i'm not like anti-facts at
all
i just think that people are rushing
into this stuff
yes but i was reading about the approval
process from the fda
did you know it's something like it's
something like six months to get to get
legitimate hard fda approval yeah so
it's probably it's going to be approved
soon
so that's why a lot of people are like
well it's an emergency authorization i
think that matters
because they now you've got canada
talking about blood clots or whatever it
definitely matters
but i'd like to see fda approval you
know what i mean like i don't think
that's unreasonable for me to be like yo
you know i don't think it's fair new
york's already rolling out the passports
here's the bigger problem it's not the
government doing it
biden's got a plan biden's working with
industry
but they can't force anybody to do
anything what's going to happen is
you're not going to be able to board a
plane you're not going to be able to buy
a ticket from ticketmaster or whatever
they're going to it's going to be social
enforcement in the private sector that's
going to make all this happen like masks
for instance
what happened in texas when they were
like yo we're done with this there was
like some
some chain of grocery stores or
something that said nope you still got
to do it i think walmart was like no you
still got to wear masks their um
infection rates are going way down
though right now yep
yeah so everything is just crazy it's
like
i don't know i live in the woods up on a
mountain
i interact with like four people a week
like i i'm just like i don't really feel
like i need anything like this
like we're fine we're up in the mountain
you guys can do your things in the city
but but yeah so what about in cities
though what if they said vaccine
passports only in
the city and not in the mountains i mean
i i don't care
i am not i don't want to go to cities i
hate going to cities so
i'll stay up on the mountain you guys
can get your papers down there
when did you do you used to live in big
cities yeah i hate them i like
what happened so i haven't been back to
a city since i moved
to west virginia or i hadn't until last
week because i had to take my cat to an
emergency
vet and it was the whole thing but he
had to go get surgery in richmond
and i went there and i was like wow this
is like the walking dead or something
like this like apocalyptic yeah it was
just everybody's walking around
masks they're all like i don't know it's
just really weird because i hadn't
for the past almost a year i've been up
you know in the mountain you know where
where i am pretty isolated like we go to
the country store nobody wears a mask
trying to buy a bunch of right wing nut
jobs yeah i love my right wing nut job
community
but uh yeah everything's like normal
like you have to wear a mask if you go
to like the big chain stores
like if you go to walmart or something
but if you go to like the local nursery
or the country store
you're not going to see people wearing
masks and they're going to get looked at
funny if you
if they do yeah yeah they're like you
should take that mask off
yeah and i'm like well it's your
business you know what i mean like
that's that's interesting thing about
the whole mask thing like what if a
business tells you you can't wear masks
and people are like well it's like my my
view is the private business man if
if it's that's the challenge with a lot
of this passport stuff is that it's
social enforcement
yeah if every business is saying we all
do this then what do you do
yeah i guess you just get your passport
right
that's what makes me think this bad
information is freaky like
flu numbers are down covered numbers are
up is that right like they were the flu
numbers were way
down but those covered numbers were way
up and they were like oh
equal amounts of deaths is normal but
this time it's no flu deaths it's all
coveted deaths
yeah but that could be spurious
correlation maybe
like could be that's the thing they
don't know but they want to force a
vaccine it's crazy but i'll say this
so one of the things that they've been
saying for a long time is that
putting people locking people inside
their home is a mistake because covet
transmits easier
easier indoors so it could be that
putting people in their house makes flu
go down but then spreads cove it easier
so it was like the dumbest thing they
could have done but not you know
yeah i think that's like a simple
solution i suppose
but when you have in europe they were
like if you're pregnant don't get it if
you have food allergies don't get it
then i'm like okay i won't you know what
i mean i'll chill i'm not in a rush i
think some
something like 50 of people said they're
willing to just wait and take it easy
that's what's really interesting when
fox runs a story and they're like
everyone's
longing for this you know reopening i'm
like most people that they're willing to
wait on the vaccine because their
concerns about
you know potential long-term effects
that haven't been studied properly
yeah i might be in like a weird
right-wing bubble because like my
community are all
you know normal seen people who are not
freaking out about anything
and but i'm i'm perfectly happy not
getting a passport staying on my
mountain
my garden ordering yeah
everything gets delivered to my house i
don't even go grocery shopping so it's
like
okay you guys enjoy your passport
living in the mountains so here's the
crazy thing though virginia's red
i mean i'm sorry west virginia's red and
virginia's blue like like even right
where west virginia and virginia kind of
meet
it's crazy how i've i've got i've gone
out there and talked to people
and they're liberals well no the border
of west virginia and virginia
they're very red like you drive that
area it's all farmland and you're going
to see like trump signs
everywhere and i feel really bad for
them actually because it's like they
don't get a vote
west virginia actually um i think it was
about a year ago
offered to take those counties into west
virginia yeah yeah yeah because it sucks
for them like they're all pro-gun
they're you know right-wing and they're
being represented by the people who
work in dc and live in the cities that
are close to dc
and you know why they don't want to live
in dc because it's horrible
because they're racist oh yeah i think i
think i absolutely think it's because
most of these well-to-do progressive
liberal types are super racist
they don't want to live in the cities
that they've destroyed with their
policies
like dc is has a very very high uh
percentage of
black residents it's no surprise that
the people who live
who who work in dc and run dc decide to
move out of dc
they don't want to they this is what
happens and now virginia's turning blue
across the board
and then they're not going to want to
live there in a year or two and they're
going to move to maryland or they're
going to move south and go you know to
north carolina or something
and slowly keep moving away from the
things they keep voting for
one of the funny things about west
virginia is i see these stories
where i was talking to a guy at a gun
shop and he was like
you can tell who the liberals are like
when they're moving in because they
complain about mountain things
that no one like no conservative cares
about yeah so like
you know someone said my neighbor left
their trash out and i
why are they doing this you know what do
i got to do to make them pick their
trash in and everyone's like
who cares my local community uh facebook
group is always like joking about that
whenever somebody new moves in they'll
be like
are you guys allowed to be shooting guns
this close to people's houses
and they're like welcome to the mountain
get ready for the utvs and atvs too
people you'll see some you know people
driving around on rascals with a couple
of ars
[ __ ] flags shout out to the united
states because
first i was in the suburbs grew up then
i went to the cities and lived that
part of my life and now in the mountains
it's like another world
it's another world it's like another
country we got this race car
it's like super nice race car and we've
got these two foot quarter pipes in the
parking lot
and we just bought it and we're kind of
like we can do whatever we want so we
just this thing can go 60 miles an hour
oh my gosh
we launched the thing like 25 feet in
the air it's flipping around and
smashes the ground is bouncing and we're
like probably gonna break it just
laughing but you can do that out here
yeah so that's the crazy thing too like
all the whole time with kovid
i've been saying that since you know
when coveted started we were in the
philadelphia area
that was actually really scary you know
you're surrounded by all these people
and then you get told like donald trump
appears on tv and he's like i'm shutting
down
travel to europe and all the stuff and
we were like damn this is serious
and we were worried too because like the
supply shortage the toilet paper was
gone
like our local walmart toilet paper all
gone the neighbor bounced
like the one name yeah the neighbor was
gone for like two months and then when
the storm
blew like the fence off it was just just
down they just abandoned their house
yeah like too much they took off i think
it was longer than that probably
it's freaky so then we ended up moving
out to the middle of nowhere
it's like paradise people just go about
their business like normal
you go down to like the local shop
nobody nobody hassles you
i just want to say though we also have
bigfoot people play their banjos really
loud all night
there's a lot of shooting like things in
their front yards
um confederate flags everywhere leftists
don't move don't move out don't move to
west virginia
you will hate it it's awful um and that
is all just had to throw that in so
that's so i tweeted
i tweeted uh i don't know if you saw the
story like lindsey graham said he has an
ar-15
you see that he's like doing an
interview and he's like i got an ar-15
and
you know if it i forgot what he said if
like it goes if it all goes bad or
whatever
the gangs this is the last place the
gangs will go because i can defend
myself
and so i tweeted lindsay is an ar15
pathetic
we should ban ar-15s outright completely
and then the government should issue
everyone a barrett m82
50 bmg semi-automatic anti-material
rifle then you'll truly i'm kidding by
the way
but you know that's that's the thing
about west virginia
is that well so i've been buying a lot
of bullets
because you know first of all they're
hard to get and then people were saying
you know you want to have what like a
thousand rounds per gun is like a good
amount yeah you have to have one store
and people got to realize this too i'm
sure to people who don't know anything
about guns a thousand rounds sounds like
a lot because it did to me when i was
first buying guns
you go to the range one time and you're
like oh i get it now yeah go through
like 120 really quick or something real
quick i mean if you're with your friends
and you're practicing you're doing
training
you're gonna go through you know a
decent amount of rounds quickly so a
thousand rounds might
you know be a couple months of
practicing at the range
if you want to take it seriously a lot
of people don't shoot that much
but for hunting people might shoot a
couple times well so i started buying
bullets and i was like i was talking to
a guy at the shop
and i was like i'm getting a bunch of
12-gauge uh and i was like is this is
this too much
does like does this notify anybody
started laughing and he was like
you think you're anywhere close to prep
territory or even west virginia resident
territory
he's like come on man those are rookie
numbers you got to pump those numbers up
i'm like
all right i'll take what you got put
them in the box and then i got like a
huge box of 12 gauge i guess
but it does go quick you know but anyway
i digress we're talking about covet
sorry i'm a west virginia fan girl
apologies
and i like ammo yeah i'm talking about
ammo
no sorry like i brought this up before
you play fallout
you know caps bottle caps is the
currency of the future after
the nuclear war i think that ammo it
would just be ammo so like you use your
ammo or you trade your ammo the ammo has
weight i think that would be a great
model super valuable yeah like mainly
another game i'm playing it's water is
the currency so you carry that around
and trade fresh water
yeah but you but it it it depends i
suppose fresh water is probably
but you're not going to be carrying on
lots of water that's the problem right
cigarettes and whiskey too
so you can find like metal copper and
stuff but ammo
cigarettes is a good one yeah
antibiotics
yes bitcoin because people will still
have phones
no yeah i don't know stuff that
disappears after you use it it's hard to
know actually because water makes sense
but you can't carry a lot of water
around with you
you can carry enough for personal use
you carry too much and then you can't
you're actually exerting water to carry
the water it's a great currency
model for a video game because of the
weight plus if you're carrying a big
thing of water on like a wagon
like your target yeah these roving bands
are going to show up you have to hide it
somehow
so maybe not water but bolts make sense
you know your bullets for sure
also heavy but i can't imagine that
maybe casings because
bullets you got to use you don't want to
give those up they're too valuable
too valuable dude the apocalypse happens
and you've got just like
five nine millimeter for your gun you're
gonna be like i will never give these
things up
you know i would never want to fire them
that's why i train with the bow and
arrow
because i don't want to waste my music
yeah all right let's check this out
let's talk let's talk about some serious
covet stuff right now because this one's
probably going to get a little bit in
trouble on youtube
daily mail reports is this the link
between astrazeneca's covet vaccine and
blood clots
shot may trigger an immune response that
leads to the life-threatening side
effect in rare cases
study claims they say about 30 cases of
blood clots among people who got a dose
of astrozenecos vaccine were reported in
europe
german researchers found signs of
antibodies that attack platelets in the
blood of nine people
who developed the clots after getting
the shot these antibodies destroy the
platelets
to make up for the loss the body
overproduces platelets causing them to
clot
the team says that if their hypothesis
is correct the reaction can
can be identified and easily treated by
medical professionals
more than 20 european countries paused
the use of asinica's shot this month
amid clot fears but subsequently resumed
its use
officials in the eu ruled the rate of
clots was not above that
in the general population but canada on
monday issued a pause on the use of
vaccine
for under 55 citing concern over clots
this is the kind of stuff that freaks me
out because
we've seen a bunch of stories and this
is what pisses me off a bunch of stories
where they're like man gets shot
shortly after dies and then you read the
stories like one month later he died and
he was 75 years old and i'm like come on
man
like dude we really need to know about
this stuff and you got a bunch of media
that wants to just freak us out and
scare us
this is legit though and i wouldn't be
surprised if youtube gets mad at us for
even talking about it but this is a
legit
news guard certified source daily mail
and they're saying
in europe they suspended it briefly and
canada they're suspending it
so i don't know what you guys think
about this but this to me
i think you know they're going to go
after people calling them anti-vaxx
if they bring anything like this up and
that's the more dangerous thing in my
opinion
yeah yeah because i mean it's a real
thing that's happening the governments
are having to suspend it
but then if you're critical of it or if
you're skeptical or if you're
nervous about taking it yourself then
you're this like crazy anti-vaxxed
monster
who believes disinformation and you
can't even discuss it
so everybody's like hiding in shame
being like
freaked out about this thing and nobody
can even talk about it vaccines are
amazing
amazing technology but if they're
misused they're super dangerous
and can kill people so that's why they
have this massive testing and
they make them go through years of
trials and stuff
why would you ever want to put yourself
in a position where you might get blood
clots
for something unless that thing is super
deadly and like gonna
mur like gonna [ __ ] you or something
what we have to look at is the rate at
which people got blood clots
and the coveted survival rate for
someone who's under 55
i got to tell you i don't see a reason
why people who are under 55
should be taking a medication that's
been suspended by the government if
canada says don't take it then the
people in canada probably can't do it
which means the passport thing the whole
vaccine passport thing is broken
it's not going to work the survival rate
for people under 55 i think is what like
99.995 or some
really really high number it's super
high young people are not
being negatively impacted by this it's
almost like a large
voting block of older people are worried
about this
and pushing for this and that's kind of
like been the narrative
for most of my life older people wanted
social security
so they vote to put money into it and
they take from it the system collapses
it's always been like
jesus look at congress they're all like
not all of them but a lot of them are
over 70.
i mean nancy pelosi is what she's 80
right yeah it's super old
a very broken system when you're
sacrificing your children to save the
old
and i i everybody's going to call me a
monster for saying that i guess but
our children are committing suicide at
super high rates right now they're
they're suffering from depression
their you know abused children are stuck
at home and not seeing teachers who
could get them out of that situation
there's all these like horrible negative
effects of what they're doing
for children right now and i mean
all of this comes down to people who are
older are afraid
and so we're sacrificing our youth in
multiple ways
um we've seen these like these videos of
the kids sitting at their desks and
they're six feet apart and surrounded by
plexiglass
it's horrible these kids are going to be
very very
developmentally stunted did you see the
mother that giving birth and there's a
plastic tarp between her and the baby
and she like squeezes the baby against
the plastic creepy
the baby's like in his face smushed on
the plastic i thought i thought
babies in like the super young were not
were like fine like covert wasn't
affecting them
like kids in schools weren't being
affected or whatever yeah people are
living in terror and they're being
arrested dude
these stories i'll tell you the big
problem is that
a sane and rational population would say
hey you know canada is suspending this
over blood clot fears
should we consider something like that
in the us and and look to these other
countries in terms of
their medical prowess and endeavors i
mean we hear all the time from the left
about the health care systems of these
other countries being
infinitely better than ours there was
recently a story where i guess like
norway was
was calling the us an underdeveloped
medical
uh uh system which is just ridiculous by
the way it was clearly just the
stupidest thing ever
like you may talk about the the payment
systems being screwed up in the
pharmaceutical companies and the way the
money goes to the insurance companies
fine but we got advanced technology here
in terms of medicine
but they were mocking the us saying
underdeveloped it was like be wary of
traveling to countries with
underdeveloped healthcare systems for
example the united states hahaha very
funny
yet tons of people come here for
medication anyway the point is
if we can't have a conversation about
okay fine these other countries
are taking this seriously then we're in
trouble yeah
and that's it it's almost as if we have
an overly
qualified medical like our basically
what i'm thinking about is potassium
bromate or i think it's bromide or
bromate it's a leave-in agent and bread
that's
cause causes cancer it's been known to
be where they carcinogenic
and europe most of europe has banned it
from their bread products but the united
states has not
so it's a big problem that the medical
that the pharmaceutical chemical
industry
has more sway than common sense
sometimes what i'm saying is that
i'm talking about the media i'm talking
about the fact that we'll be like
wow canada is suspending their their
their their you know vaccine for people
under 55.
they're going to call scientificers
they're going to insult smear and say
they were questioning it it's like no
dude and the leavening agent is
obviously there's evidence that it's
carcinogenic yet the media why would the
media not be like well let's get it out
of our bread products if it's causing
cancer
they don't care like that's that's not
in the news cycle they want to sell that
stuff
brominated vegetable oils and like oh
it's so bad for people
too sure sure like evidently the media
cares about
protecting the status quo and the
establishment there's no
national conversation about bromine
there's a national conversation about
covet and vaccines
and so they want to toe the line they
want to mimic the status quo and they
want to write what other outlets write
and if they find you as an other it'll
work i think
the big problem it's really annoying to
me are we are we really in the minority
are we the silent majority is it
which is it is is this country 80 a
bunch of really dumb
people who are like i'm not going to
talk about anything and i'm going to sit
here and plug my ears and just do
whatever i'm told
terrifyingly the data says yes i think
that it's like 90
of people are kind of followers yeah see
now that i'm
in my my beautiful right-wing bubble
in west virginia i just can't like
it seems like everybody doesn't want it
and that everybody has common sense
about it that you know they think that
people who are very elderly should take
it
and that people who are younger should
not um and that's just like the common
all the conversations that you have with
people in my neighborhood
that's what it is and then you see it
online and
everybody just acts like that's a
completely crazy unreasonable fringe
take
so it it's very disconnected for me i
saw something really funny today
it was brian stelter from reliable
sources saying asking if
the nash if the white house press corps
like the the national
press is out of sync with the american
people or whatever and i'm like man it
took you this long
wow it's been like children who are
wrong yeah six years
it's the yeah are we out of sync you
know what i realize is really funny
when there was a story in the new york
times about
a party someone from the new york times
had been to a few years prior
and they were like canceled over it or
something and i'm like what
regular american is like i'm going to
turn to the new york times for the
important news
janet went to a party three years ago
and got cancelled for being racist
wow that's the news i pay for but people
pay for it
their subscribers are it's going up
they're making more and more money
journalists write about each other and
i'm like who are you talking to yeah
what who is this but you know what man
it's frustrating because
i was at you know we went out to a bar
the other day and there was a guy who
made a really great point he said
look the vaccine's here it's available
we're done
it should be over if you don't want to
get it that's your problem i'll be fine
because he was like he said he was
getting the vaccine and i'm like totally
agree
why should we have a vaccine passport
system why should we
mass mandate or any social distancing
when the people who get the vaccines
will
be fine if someone chooses not to get it
well then you're the one person who's
going to get it nobody else will
i don't understand the logic well the
logic is if you don't get the vaccine
and you carry it
then you can transport it to other
people or but if you're vaccinated
you're fine according to fauci
you may still need to wear a mask
because you're not immune if you get the
vaccine
you're not what do you say i i wanted to
speak to this because fauci and joe
biden
all these people are still wearing masks
after they've gotten the vaccine
what is the point of getting a vaccine
if nothing changes i'm starting to feel
like they're waging a war of
demoralization on the american people
and this is still an idea in development
because they don't understand why
they're doing it they don't know if the
vaccine is effective we are the test
they do but they do they do know if it's
effective i mean they've done numerous
tests
the issue is is it is safety versus
freedom
it is easier for them to be like i would
rather just be
safe peter hitchens wrote this wrote
this op-ed about getting the vaccine and
he was like i
you know i got the vaccine and all it
cost me was my freedom and i'm like
look man i think the bigger issue is
that there's no trust
in our public institutions anymore we're
hyper polarized and we don't like each
other
because if we were actually a unified
country combating this great villain we
would be like
yes we got to get everyone vaccinated
we'd be like cheering for it would be
only a few people
who opposed it yeah exactly everyone
comes together right no we're fractured
nobody trusts each other the media's
garbage they're like
writing about each other and and other
nonsense they write about oh no glenn
greenwald
we got to write about him now who cares
stop writing about other people
that's the problem with a lot of it the
media really killed their credibility
during the trump administration i mean
they were selling the american public a
horror movie
and now they don't have much else to
write about
so they're trying to create all these
villains and and everybody's just like
what are you doing like none of this
is relevant to me and so when they do
put out information
about things like vaccines or kovid
people are skeptical
rightly because for years we've been fed
russiagate and all this crazy nonsense
from the media
the p-tape like all this stuff that's
just like completely insane that they've
been feeding us for so long
how are you supposed to trust them when
there's something actually serious
um i look at this some i agree with that
russiagate was so stupid
didn't have evidence i mean or maybe it
didn't have enough evidence
to warrant that amount of what's her
name the girl with the short hair
yeah maddow's obsession with it for two
years it was like she like
cried oh my god but what i'm thinking
about is
a level of cognitive dissonance also
that we're looking at because i think
that obesity is a big part of this
epidemic
and like what sixty percent of people
what were these numbers i want to get
this again
of people that have covet are obese or
60 of people that are obese
yeah that's insane 78 of covet patients
were obese
well but look you know i'll add to this
people who are
out of shape unhealthy and sick are much
more likely to die in general
and so you add in you know covid which
is i think the mortality rate is like
double the flu so it's like
substantially higher
and you're going to get a ton of people
who are who have comorbidities dying
from this thing and if they're lucky
people
i don't want to stop drinking pepsi i
don't want to stop eating red meat every
night
but you i want you to get a shot that
that may or may not work so that i can
feel a little better it's like dude take
care of yourself
the issue is they believe the vaccines
will work
however it's easier just to say
safety over freedom that's why i was
bringing up that point from the guy in
the bar who's like we get the vaccine
it's on you now it's your responsibility
i'm like that's a great point he was
provex
he was bragging about how he was getting
his co his code vaccine was really
excited
and he was like and now it's your
problem because you're the one who's
going to get sick not me
and i'm like that's right he's like a
liberal guy
and i'm like that's that's perfect logic
or people have a choice take care of
themselves they don't want to do it or
yeah so so the issue is when it comes to
fauci when it comes to body when it
comes to all these companies
listen imagine walmart you know they're
being told everyone's doing a covid
passport or whatever
and they say no no we're not going to do
that because it's on the individual
well then somebody gets sick and then
sues walmart right because you can sue a
ham sandwich doesn't mean you're going
to win
so walmart's like it is easier just to
go with the flow and do whatever we're
told
because then at least we can have
plausible deniability or or reject
liability in the event someone gets sick
in our store
then we'll just beg oh no no we have the
passport everybody's supposed to be
you know so i remember when i worked for
fusion they made me do this hostile
environment training
even though i had spent like several
years already in hostile environments
and so it was fairly there's some really
cool thing aspects to it
fairly rudimentary in my opinion at
least relevant to my experience
and i was like i was talking to the
people about why are they
you know making me do this i have
extensive field experience and conflict
in crisis
and they're like well you know it's just
good and i want insurance isn't it
well you know yeah because if i get hurt
and then i say well they didn't give me
the proper training so they're just like
it's easier to just make you do the
stupid training course you don't need to
do and waste the money
and time because in the event you get
hurt we don't want to get too the big
problem with corporations and insurance
and all that is that they look at people
like numbers and they just treat us like
like a math equation i think that we're
i think we're seeing the same problem at
two different levels we're seeing a lack
of responsibility in people who refuse
to take care of themselves and you're
seeing a lack of responsibility
responsibility from these companies who
are like we're not having anything to do
with it
you know we're not going to assume any
kind of responsibility for whatever
happens here
and they you know they don't want to be
sued i get it at the same time it's like
you need to like have some kind of
accountability like they'd rather poison
i would imagine the corporate beast of
walmart would rather poison the
population
than suffer a bankruptcy so
i think about it this way when it comes
to politics do you think
any one of these politicians actually
cares about you they
not me because they don't know who i am
no they they can't care about it
they don't even know because when they
look at the numbers look if it was
an election between 100 people between
you know and they're like okay you're
going to vote for me as 100 people i
need to win 51 votes
you actually could care about each of
those people because you can meet them
and know them
and then actually convince them to vote
for you when it comes to a politician
who needs
50 000 votes in a local election
they can't spend time knowing everybody
so they don't care
all of these systems have have developed
that way walmart
target whatever the store is the movie
theaters they look at their numbers
and they're like we had 50 000 people
come in this week to see a movie
we don't know who they are we don't care
who they are a hundred of them got sick
okay we'll ban those people i don't know
we don't know them they're just numbers
i'll put it this way when when i look at
my youtube video account
i see it a number 250 000.
i don't know any of the people who watch
that the number is meaningless to me
and when i look at analytics i see this
in a bunch of other news outlets this is
why the media becomes what it is
they don't care about the individual
they don't care about their
ramifications
rachel maddow says donald trump an agent
of russia
and then all of a sudden she looks at
the number and the number's bigger and
she's like hey look it said 2.7 yeah
that says 3.1 we should do the same
thing again not realizing that she was
contributing to driving people insane
now i absolutely self-reflected on all
of that stuff and was like
i don't know what the solution is if
we're all you know genuinely having
these opinions and we're talking about
them
and in the end many people are driven by
looking at their analytics
every company looking at their marketing
numbers every politician
not caring at the individual just doing
whatever it takes to make that number go
up but that means
people are driven by confirmation bias
so this is what happens to the media
rachel maddow's like just keep saying
the same thing over and over again the
numbers keep going up
until they can't anymore that's that's
the reality here as well
when they're looking at it's like a cost
benefit and a cost risk
analysis you know you guys you ever see
fight club where he's on the plane
and he's like if the cost of a lawsuit
is uh is less than the cost of a recall
we'll just take the lawsuit basically
that's the way it works
so you look at fouchy you look at the
government and they're like
the cost of forcing people to stay home
is lower than the cost of the risk
should something go bad
just make everybody stay home and we
used to be we we
we came from this group of people and in
fact i'll tell you this my props to all
of the immigrants
who are you know climbing mountains and
riding trains and
wandering through 90 miles of desert to
get here because those people have more
pioneer blood in them
than most of these urban progressives
and suburban uppity do liberals
who are like i'd rather just be safe now
these people are like i'm going to cross
a mountain
and rip my feet to shred and be abused
and victimized by cartels but i'm coming
to america for that american dream
i respect that a heck of a lot more than
people who are like i just want to be
safe it's like that meme you know the of
the shiba inu being all ripped and
strong
and it's like um you know colonists
coming from europe
dying on the boat halfway there landing
on a shore with nothing but trees and
being like
i'm finding freedom america today just
keep me safe
that's what we get that's my rant
i think that the further you get from
these things the easier it becomes to
shrug it off
i think part of the reason that eastern
europe is still strong
against communism is because they
freaking
remember they remember what communism
was like and once they start to forget
it's all over i mean that was not even
30 years ago it wasn't that long ago
yeah luke luke who's been on the show
frequently i don't know where luke you
left all your stakes here look like luke
made his bible stakes are frozen luke we
bought all these peter luger sticks like
you got to get peter lewis
save them for me keep them in the
freezer all right they're in the freezer
dude
but anyway he was born he was born in
soviet uh
god that's part of why so on the
satellite state of the soviet union but
he was born into
you know that that system made him cool
left when he was a little kid
but i think it ended when he was very
young his parents and his like uncles
and aunts
went through it pretty hardcore yeah so
he was told a lot about it
i don't think he saw with his own eyes i
don't know if he saw [ __ ] he doesn't
really talk about the horror a lot
you really got to kind of pry it out of
him i would you know what i'd love to do
i'd love to do like a a
an ancestry analysis of the people who
support critical race theory
and where where their grandparents were
during the civil rights movement
because i got a feeling that there's
going to be some correlation between
the status quo loving uppity do
anti-civil rights white folk and the
critical race theorists of today
either one for one or two reasons like
it was a backlash
these people you know are ashamed of
their history and ancestry they're
overtly racist their families racist and
so they're like yes
they're gonna come out and admit their
racism and then do everything they can
to recognize and acknowledge all of
these racial you know issues and
everything
i wonder about that because you
mentioned you know for luke his parents
told him
about what it was like in communism so
he naturally hates it
so what about these uppity do critical
race theory people did they learn about
segregation
or not that they're actually supporting
it these days
or actually i guess using communist
tactics
which brings me to our next story
check this out this is this is where it
gets just real crazy man
daily mail reports cops investigate
virginia teachers facebook group
for naming parents who were against
critical race theory
and urging members to gather information
on them
they say the anti-racist parents of
luden county group shared personal
details of those they say had opposed
moves to teach the controversial
curriculum
i'm glad they're calling it
controversial it urged followers to
quote
gather information and silence critics
of the theory
others in the group encouraged people to
share addresses and social media
according to purdue university critical
race theory scholarship
shows how racism can excuse me continues
to be persuasive
and why it denies individuals their
rights talk about
double speak on that one that's nuts but
critics say it leaves people exposed
to the training feeling that they are
being blamed for problems which they did
not cause
and that itself is racially divisive
it's overtly
racially discriminatory and racist one
parent on the list
patty mender says i was personally
attacked lcps interim superintendent
scott ziegler said
we fully support the expression of first
amendment rights
and deplore any efforts to silence
voices
all right i got a question who who is
the lcps superintendent talking about
right there
he says we we we fully support the first
amendment and deplore efforts to silent
voices i'm guessing the teachers because
the liberals run all the school boards
so but wait wait
is he defending the people who are being
doxed because he was threatening to
silence them yeah or is he defense he
doubt right so he's defending the doxing
you're right yeah man this is
we did have the civil rights you're
right and a lot of people weren't privy
to it unfortunately
but like united states has never been a
totalitarian dictatorship
so there's this threat of us falling
into it
seamlessly and man it looks like looks
like that's what that's what this is
it but listen it's social enforcement
this is the big thing
from the bottom up that's where it gets
really creepy
and then once people lose confidence in
government which is literally happening
i mean look at the six for instance
people are losing confidence in the
system
and then you get a bottom-up movement of
cultists who are just
the only thing they care about is being
in their cult
look these people were posting for years
anti-asian sentiments all over social
media
all over the place and then one day the
tide shifted and the cult decided that
was wrong now
and now they're trying to cancel
themselves because some of them were
posting anti-asian stuff
there is no rule there's no there's no
rule there's no structure to this
it's literally just a cult man at least
with christianity there's a bible
and people can follow tenets and
understand and read through it
and i certainly believe there are
instances where people selectively you
know will choose to follow
some things but there's literally a
bible you can look at it and yes
it's been re-translated and changed i'm
critical of that but for now in the
united states
the king james bible there you go you
read it you know what it says could you
imagine if one day they were like an
editing board was just came out and
they're like
on page you know 232 we actually changed
this one
you actually can eat shellfish now oh
we're good basically that's what they
did the council of nicea
i know for sure that's why i'm saying
that we twisted that thing we can be
critical of that
but at the very least right now in the
united states and for the past several
generations the bible's been the bible
yeah for hundreds of years king james
twisted his own version into reality
but with critical race theories it's not
even written down at the very least they
had to
translate it and argue about it right
yeah i think the
black lives matter had like tenets on
their web page that they
yes they stripped from the web page and
they no longer have that was kind of the
the bible i mean that's disrupting the
nuclear family yeah
check this out from the daily mail san
francisco school board
strips vice president of her leadership
title and removes her from all
committees
over 2016 tweets calling asians
i'm just i'm not going to repeat i'm not
going to say the word racial disparaging
racial term for black people
but she still refuses to resign so this
woman
this uh her what is her name allison is
her name allison collins anti-asian
tweets
oh yes allison collins she posted that
she wanted to have she give asians a
racial awakening
total cult stuff and then she referred
to them in a very racist and disparaging
way
like outright using a racial slur now
they're calling for her to resign
this is all sorts of screwed up for
several reasons for one
this is the vice president of a school
board in san francisco
the people who are indoctrinating your
kids using racial slurs
and then claiming to be anti-racist
that's why that's why i mentioned like
who are these people's parents and
grandparents
homeschool your kids yeah yes
i think that we can't beat them by
insulting them
and calling them horrible for being
racist i just feel like the only way is
to like
it's so maybe it's so obnoxious to say
this over and over again but it's to
create a better system
to be a pinnacle of what you believe in
which i think equality of opportunity
of all of us whatever we look like i
don't really care um
and and then capitalism and roll around
in that
but this is interesting to talk about
too like i almost
completely ignore this stuff in my daily
life i focus on
community communication organization
and there is a value calling out the
problem pros and cons though
if you ignore them right they fester you
have to call it out the problem is
that the left is working really hard to
get to children younger and younger i
mean they're putting stuff on sesame
street they're
getting critical race theory into
elementary schools they're doxing
parents for having wrong think
there's a school i think in north
carolina or south carolina
where they actually did a conference
instructing parents
to go up against i mean to instructing
the teachers to go up against and
contradict the parents
of the the students i mean there's just
all this stuff going on the left is
targeting children with their agenda
and the right is largely like we're
going to lead by example and we're going
to
you know we don't want to keep kids out
of politics we're going to take the high
road we're not going to stoop to their
level
but we're we're losing because of it
that's that's a cultural revolution
having the kids indoctrinating them and
then telling them to reject their
parents yeah
hardcore culture revolution i was like
disgusted i i posted about it for
gateway i forget the name of the
reporter he's doing amazing work on
on uh critical race theory stuff right
now that's happening
but he had a whole report about this
this
conference and you read it and it's just
like
we're letting this happen i mean school
board elections
don't have party affiliation listed
which i know you support but i
don't because we're getting all these
leftists who are going into red areas
and they're deliberately going in there
so they can counter what the children
are learning at home from their parents
who are right-wing
i hate it that's crazy but but i think
it's a bigger problem that people have
have given up on their civic
responsibility right so i i think
yeah you agree with me on removing party
affiliation big time yeah i was just
studying ancient greece last night i was
telling you i was watching like a
visualization of
virtualization of athens and like they
were talking about the politics and like
they would take
50 500 people from around every like of
all
50 from all the 10 areas of attica bring
them to greece to athens and then they
would all be part of politics and then
50 of those 500 would get chosen
to be like the head of the council this
is everybody every citizen
every i think they were only males at
the time but every citizen male citizen
and they were all involved and they were
all super excited to like adjudicate
lawsuits about like people are they
guilty or they were just so involved
everyone was so involved in the politics
of the day
i think we need that well so so now what
happens is
you get these leftists these marxists
they'll run and be on the school board
and then what people are going to be
like this person sounds nice and just
vote for them
well the problem is yes all of this
stuff would be great in a
utopia like where we don't have
political parties
ideally i would like there to not be
political parties either
but there are and so when you have
school board elections you don't have
people named
these people are running on things like
we're going to get new school buses
we're going to help build a new football
team
they're not talking about whether or not
they're going to be pushing critical
race theory
and people who live in these red areas
assume that these are people from their
communities
who have you know similar culture and
values
so they're not necessarily digging as
hard as they should be and a lot of
these people are learning it right now
i've seen it happening in quite a few
towns out in west virginia
but um it's it's a problem because
people don't realize
i mean they're just like you know what
you know what they say when you assume
yes yeah it's i can't i don't feel like
oh
i know yeah we make a butt out of you
and you
i think almost that we should be voting
for smart contracts and not people
because if those people are telling you
we're going to do this this and this and
then they go in and they
also do that and that we didn't vote for
that right
we voted for their contract that's true
interesting that's a good point actually
politicians should be like these are the
only things i plan to implement and they
should have a very comprehensive package
because that's that's a really really
good point think about andrew yang for
instance one of the reasons i liked him
was that his
policy proposals were off was like nuts
like the dude sat down and just started
writing
a book about all the policies he wanted
he had one on like mma
unions and stuff and i'm like man this
guy's what yeah exactly
legit telling you like here's what i
want to do now i guess the problem is
like
like you know you guys both point out if
someone comes to you and says
no no i'm not gonna do all those really
bad things i'm only gonna do the really
good things and then you're like then i
vote for that then i choose you to do
those things then as soon as
soon as they're elected they're like now
i'm gonna do the things you hate and not
the things you like
well we should be able to be like nah
regis of grievances
you ran on this slate of proposals
you are not implementing them instead
you're bringing in you know critical
race theory
they should be able to be removed
instantly there needs to be a way to do
like an immediate emergency recall well
thanks to kovit at least the one good
thing that's come out of this is that
kids
have been learning at home so parents
are seeing what they're getting taught
and they're
a lot of them are getting a rude
awakening like real bad
and so i think that that the one good
thing that might come out of this is
that parents
are going to be looking more into the
education system
in west virginia i'm sorry i'm a west
virginia fan girl
yesterday jim justice or it might have
been today um
that was today justice signed a bill um
where now
we're going to be funding students
instead of institutions
so is it like a voucher system or how
does it yeah it's i'm so excited about
this wait
it's literally like a voucher thing
where like you can use it for home
school you can do
private school charters that's a
revolution man it's
so cool i am amped about this this is
something that i've
been talking about for even years even
before i was on the right
but uh yeah it just got signed into law
i think it goes into effect in 90 days
90 of west virginia children are going
to be eligible for it
it's wonderful that means if parents
homeschool their kids
they're going to get a cash stipend for
covering costs and stuff like that yeah
i think they're called hope scholarships
i could be wrong
don't quote me on that but it's
something hope something but they're
gonna do like
savings accounts where you basically can
access this money that is for the
child's education
and you can put it towards public school
or private school or whatever you want
teachers unions obviously are outraged
because who the heck wants to send their
kid to public school if there's other
options
uh it's glorious right you know what i
think yay justice
we've become a very dull people and i'm
thinking of dole in terms of
like color saturation we are
we're we are all such npcs and i don't
mean like you or i
or you know lydia or ian specifically
i'm awesome yeah you're great the best
just sorry obviously not us
though i do think we're duller in a
sense
than the people who came before us yeah
what i mean is that people have really
just given
everything up where are the parents to
be like
i want to go to my school and be
involved and now they don't know that
marxism critical race or whatever you
want to call it is is seeping in well
before my daughter was homeschooled
because
she went to public school for about a
year and a half
i was very involved in the school and i
didn't know half the stuff that they
were teaching because they don't do it
in front of the parents like i went in i
volunteered every friday i
went in as like a teacher's assistant
and i would help with crafts and
cleaning and stuff like that
i went on all the field trips i was
involved in like parents groups
and you don't know any of the stuff i
mean when i was there we actually had a
huge scandal
and the freaking school administration
was threatening to call the cops on all
of us
because the 14 year old student got
raped in the bathroom
by two adult
um illegal immigrants that were wait
what that happened
yeah in rockville the rockville rape now
they say it wasn't rape and that it was
consensual but the fact of the matter is
it was a 19 year old who is in high
school with our our kids
um having sex with a 14 year old and
another guy
they took photos of it the whole thing
was
horrif like horrible and so me and a
whole bunch of other parents were upset
about it and we started writing being
like hey how many adults are going to
school with our children
and there was nothing about race at all
i mean i was still a leftist back then
who were these guys like why were they
there they were adult illegal immigrants
and they got they're placing them into
the high schools because they're
they're at such a lower learning curve
that they
they're getting placed some of them in
middle schools and so
we all wanted to know how many adults
were going there was nothing about race
there was nothing about immigration we
just wanted to know how many adults were
in the schools they sent a school
district-wide email
saying that racism will not be tolerated
that they'll call the police
it was wild i mean i pulled my daughter
out of school like two weeks later but
i'm so sick of the cult man yeah it's
it's it's so amazing
and the only reason it works is because
people have become
dull when when listen when someone comes
out
and you're like i don't like the fact
that a child was
you know attacked and they go you're
racist shut your
mouth yeah they like swearing almost i
mean they red-pilled a lot of moms that
day
yeah there was i mean i was in involved
with all these parent groups everybody
was super liberal
but as soon as that email came out we
all started messaging each other being
like what the hell is this
like it was crazy safety yeah the
school's just thinking about what's the
easiest way out
and so they're just throwing spaghetti
at the wall seeing what sticks yeah yeah
i don't know just call them racists
they blocked me on twitter because i
started tweeting about it too the school
district blocked me
and i was and i wasn't that's in west
virginia no that was back when i lived
in
uh just outside dc right it was
rockville the rockville right
there was a ton of coverage of it i mean
i was sending all the emails to
everything nowadays now in west virginia
the kid comes to school and they hand
them a gun
there's your gun welcome to school they
used to do that back in the day didn't
they
they had gun clubs at the schools
you i was thinking i was thinking about
you know
guns and gun rights and i think i
realized something when you first start
buying guns and getting into it you
realize
we're totally desensitized to cars i
know cars aren't
created for the purpose of killing
people so i get that part of the left
left left argument cars are dangerous
cars kill a lot of people
very very very very often and i think
about how we walk through busy streets
you go to new york and like somebody
will just walk through a busy street as
cars are flying past them because they
know people will use their brakes
why don't they have that same level of
trust in somebody walking down the
street with a gun
that's a really good point i know and
i've seen kids
they they're just like arrogantly walk
in the street and the car will slow down
and start honking at them
angrily or look at the ante for people
who go around surrounding cars and
smashing them
they know no one's going to do anything
to him yet when it comes to guns
the assumption is that like every
law-abiding citizen will just go nuts
and start shooting randomly
i think because guns are unique they're
not transport vehicles
like their only job is to fire a bullet
basically which is you basically a
killing tool it's not necessarily true
you can also consider them a deterrent
if you see somebody with a gun you're
not going to mess with them
but i i see i see your point but what
i'm saying is
don't you trust people kind of dude
sometimes i drive down the road and i'm
like whoa okay
two tons of metal going past each other
120 miles an hour
calculated both 60 in each direction all
it take and we're just trusting that
neither one of us is gonna
it's amazing isn't it think about this
i'm driving down a west virginia road
and it's like 55 mile limit
and there's a thin yellow paint strip in
the middle of the road
to stop me in another car which is like
two feet from me from slamming in with
the full force of 110 miles an hour and
i was just
mutilating it right to answer your
question yeah i trust people on
like explicitly i don't i'm constantly
holding the
oh i don't know i call it the o-s-h
yeah i call it
that's what i realized when i would like
you know walk around west virginia i see
people with guns all the time
and i'm just like i'm not worried about
any of these people doing anything to me
because i'm not worried about
cars either so you're becoming
desensitized to it because i bet if
people had never seen a car and they
were first time they'd be terrified yeah
like it's coming right for me but since
we're like two or three they're like
what look both ways
at the car i mean in the very beginning
they probably were probably terrified of
the noise
yeah the speed and i'm just you just get
used to it it's trust man
regular people are all right but guess
what sometimes people ram cars into
people
like some like we see these videos man
and there's some really awful instances
that have happened to that van thing in
europe so
we've just become so accustomed and
desensitized the fact that regular
people just want to live their lives
sometimes people drink and drive i think
a lot of it is situational too though
when i lived in dc when i heard gunshots
i would get scared and i would like
contemplate calling the police or going
look if there's somebody like dying
outside
when i hear gunshots in west virginia we
all say like it sounds like freedom
because you know that it's just like one
of your neighbors doing target practice
in the yard yeah think about it so it's
different
think about it this way if you are in an
area
where guns are and you know what people
are doing with the guns
you're not worried right people like you
know they're they're shooting at the
range down
in the mountain you know shooting it you
know with it with a really great
backstop
and if you're in a big city and you hear
car noises you're fine
now imagine this you're in the middle of
nowhere on top of a mountain there's no
roads anywhere for like 15 miles and you
hear
cars driving around you're gonna freak
out right like if you're in your cabin
in the woods on your property it's like
a you know
20 acres or something in the middle of
nowhere or you're on some resort
and you hear cars driving around and
there's no roads you'll probably wake up
like what is going on you'll freak out
imagine if you were you know vacationing
somewhere in a private community and
then you hear
a weird noise that doesn't belong
doesn't matter if it's car or otherwise
same thing is true for guns when you're
in dc and you know the only reason
people are shooting us because they're
criminals it's going to freak you out
yeah
i mean and it's weird because it's kind
of backwards for me now i live on like a
dead end road
so when i hear cars i get freaked out
but
when i hear gunshots i'm like oh it's
just you know the neighbors even my
liberal neighbors will sit on their
front lawn
we have like one semi-liberal house in
the community and even they sit out
there and they'll like shoot off their
porch instead it's so like liberal to
you yeah
i mean they're more they probably
libertarian but whatever
they're more left than the majority of
people on our street but um
when i hear a car go by i'm always like
what the heck is that and then i'm like
oh it's just a dump truck but we don't
even have like mail
that comes to the house because i'm so
far out there yeah so when a car comes
up i'm like
who the heck what's going on but when i
hear gunshots i'm just like oh
yeah yeah i remember i was walking
through this area in west virginia
and i heard gunshots going off and i'm
like i gotta find out where those are
and i'm walking
towards the sound oh my god you know why
because the people who are there
shooting aren't insane people
they're not shooting randomly into the
woods and it's not hunting season
so i know that as long as you know i'm
i'm
if i'm gonna make my way to these people
i know they're probably target shooting
because i was told specifically by a
store that they do target shooting
i'm hearing this then i know they're
they're very very likely practicing
safety
and i'm not worried about them it's it's
just like when i'm driving
crossing the street i'm not worried
about a car crashing into me
i know that i can i see the car i don't
try making cars break for me when i when
i cross the street you know what i mean
like if you're if you have a crosswalk
i'll try to like run across quickly
but i'm not worried they're going to
slam the gas on and try and you know
steer into me
i know it's not going to happen they
don't want to do that so when i hear
shots in the middle of nowhere i know
there's a range nearby i'm like
i'm not worried that someone's going to
have an accidental discharge these
people are at a range they're shooting
i'm gonna keep following the noise and
then i end up finding the range and
there's a guy
an older guy and he was you know zeroing
in his sights for his you know hunting
rifle of some sort
and i was like hey howdy and he's like
hey how's it going he's like oh we're
about done here it's all yours i'm like
hey nice to meet you and that was it
yeah that's regular people
so how are you guys familiar with the
story of switzerland and how they do
their guns
no i was reading about them and they
start to train their kids to shoot when
they're very young this is culturally
acceptable
they go to these shooting clubs boys it
used to be a boys only thing now boys
and girls do it
from my understanding they did have like
a mandatory military service
everyone has a gun zero murder rates
everyone treats them responsible
responsibly and i i caught a little bit
of heat on twitter for saying this but i
think that gun should be viewed
not as a toy but as something that is
fun and recreational
worthy of respect a tool something
important that we need to understand and
like really grasp
i think that's what we're missing we
need to make it like a cultural norm for
guns to be acceptable
because if we don't they're just going
to be terrifying and only bad people are
going to have them
we're getting we're getting dull like
dull in color and dull and sharpness
people used to die all the time it was
crazy it was crazy
yeah people would have like 10 kids
because half of them would die i was
just telling you guys about that that
siege of
in crete where they it was a 21 year
siege where kids were born
into this city that was under siege and
they till 21 and they would
dig tunnels i mean their their life was
they would go under in tunnels they
couldn't see a guy from me to you
and they'd have knives or like bats and
try and kill each other in these tunnels
and lay mines and blow i mean it just
sounds horrible dude
horrible this was like 500 years ago
this is i'm glad we don't do that
anymore
well i know and thank god but like if
we're not careful it could degrade back
to that like that's why i'm studying
this stuff like
how do we survive if society collapses
oh you build mines under the opposing
uh fence and then you yikes it's crazy
dude
and like tunnel rats in vietnam that
would climb down into the mud
and climb in this like they'd
suffocation was a constant threat
just the the terror and horror of war
and we have grown soft to that stuff
to everyone no so it's like what's
happening now is
these these cultists are coming in
they're taking over
and it's a really weird thing like i
don't understand
this weird overlap between the liberals
the left and wokeness
because they're a bunch of hard leftists
like dsa they're as woke as woke can be
to the point where it's actually
horrifying
like that video where the guy's like
hello my name's toby he him i just like
to say a you know point of point of
privilege um
the chatter in this room is really
making it hard for me to focus everybody
guys you need to calm down the other
person goes stop saying guys
and don't and i'm like this is just
lunacy they couldn't even have a
cohesive meeting
you know so i'm i'm wondering where's
that then there's like the dirt bag left
that are pro-gun anti-woke and just
socialists
so i'm like what's this overlap so are
these cultists
are they socialists the people who are
coming in doing critical race theory in
these schools
or are they just woke cultists you know
what i mean
they're like um or there are
opportunists yeah i think they're
marxists
so they're like all about redistribution
of the means of production or what
yeah and they're also on a power trip a
lot of this i think
isn't even political necessarily i think
that some people got bullied in high
school and now they want to get back at
the world by bullying everybody else
i honestly think that a lot of it
is not political i think that it's just
power it's a cult yeah that's all it is
and that's what i was saying earlier
it's like the rules
don't exist they change on a whim
because the real goal is that there's a
the real issue is that there is a
chaotic destructive force that just
seeks to infect and destroy and it has
no real goals like think about what the
woke stuff is doing
what is it doing it's vengeance
destroying businesses
yeah it's also corroding culture and
destroying
enterprises and business people want to
be avengers in real life they want to
they want to
avenge their past torture from being
bullied
i know because i went through it in 2006
i started making youtube videos i was
like wow
if i want to destroy anyone right now i
could get a crowd of people
to go destroy their lives not not
physically but just
basically it was pre-cancelled culture
pre-docs pre all that stuff but i
realized how powerful it was this
ostracization and how
humiliation of people i could use
because i'd like 10 000
people would watch and i'd be like yo
call this guy on this day
everyone call him at this time and let
him know this this information and then
do it let's do it again tomorrow
and like i the power of the crowd it was
and i so i i didn't allow myself to fall
thank god
think about it this way you said the
avengers marvel movies were amazing
making tons of money everybody really
likes them
and they started getting a little woke
and then people started complaining a
little bit
you know their black panther got some
heat which i don't think was entirely
undeserved but i like black panther i
give it a 7 out of 10.
captain marvel got roasted and it
absolutely deserved it now they all made
a ton of money don't get me wrong
but it's like that was the
biggest cultural institution we had
in film like the marvel movies are each
movie's over a billion dollars
event end game was like the biggest
movie for a while i guess avatar got
re-released
and then they infect it and infect it in
fact infect it with
this cult that starts just destroying
what makes it interesting
then you start seeing you know some of
the moves that come out are not as good
and the writing gets a little weaker and
it's like
eating at the base of what makes things
fun and interesting and slowly eroding
and destroying them it creates nothing
it does nothing that's why i think
marxism makes sense these people want to
completely destroy
what culture there is to create a new
one they want to they want to erase it
first so they're not producing anything
they're going to destroy everything and
then from the from the ashes they will
try to build anew
i'm not familiar enough with marxism um
like communism like china is like a
pseudo
or like a neo-communist it's not a real
communist state it's like
it's just totalitarianism yeah it's a
weird like amalgamation of communism and
capitalism and
and so there probably is a new word for
it maybe what these people are doing is
a new word for like a neo marxism
i i would say it's fair to say real
communism has never been tried
and then you must add the caveat to that
because every single time someone does
try to do or i'm sorry i'm sorry no
that's wrong real communism has never
been implemented and the issue is that
every time real communism is tried
they end up just killing tons and tons
of people millions of people
and so that says to me that every single
time you try
you will not be able to successfully
implement your utopian vision of
full-on communism it's a feature yeah
well so the general ideas people have
and that's why they don't believe
that they ignore the history is they're
like gotta keep trying gotta keep trying
they have this this magic view that
we're all gonna live in a utopia that
we're all just gonna be holding hands
and singing under a rainbow
and then everyone will own everything
and it's just garbage nonsense fairy
tales
so then someone says i'm gonna try and
do it hello good sir ian
i'm going to make a communist utopia
utopias we've all dreamed would you like
to join yes or no
absolutely cassandra would you like to
join my communist utopia
sure you would lydia would you yes
congratulations none of you have to die
wait i haven't i'm having second
thoughts
oh i've got a glock nine millimeter here
not about this oh it's too late
now there's no one left to oppose my
utopian vision
that's exactly what happens every time
it doesn't work because people say
two words i disagree
well i'm gonna have to kill you i guess
so i mean that's essentially what
they're doing to people like digitally
now
they're making it so people can't get
jobs they can't get bank accounts i mean
they're they're effectively like trying
to kill people
that's what i mean that's why it just
becomes authoritarianism
yeah you know you call it fascism if you
want and the left says we'll finish this
actually i don't care what you want to
call it doesn't matter it's a bunch of
psychopathic violent morons who are
going to destroy
everything because they want power
they're not smart enough to make a
machine work so they're going to throw a
wrench in it
you need some authority like obviously a
local level of authority you need a
sheriff maybe you don't need a sheriff
these days but
seems like you need a local order sure
but top down
authority is very dangerous that's the
path that's the last lesson i've learned
i was talking to
this anarchist dude about how in like
was it uh
uh acapulco is it marco poco not an
archipelago
yeah uh it's very anarchistic
and you know that's what they do and
archipoca and i and i was like
this guy's telling me he's like look
where i live there's no government
there's no police there's no law and
everyone gets along just fine
and i was like so what would happen if
you like walked into your neighbor's
house and took his stuff
he's like i'd probably shoot me i'm like
oh because you have a general
understanding about what isn't isn't
acceptable right
of course so people work and i was like
listen
the the general understanding of what is
or isn't acceptable is the basic
formation of government between people
a social order that exists so you're not
in
okay fine i get it you call it anarchy
and there's no authority so and without
archie authority that i understand
but there is government people are armed
and
so let me ask you another question if
someone comes into your house and takes
your stuff
would your neighbors help you stop that
person yes congratulations you formed a
small government
that there's no exchange of of of of of
currency
you just agree we live here we're in
charge and if someone comes and tries to
take from us we're going to use force
against them
scale that up and you get more and more
government so it's really simple to
start creating government
and then you take a look at these small
anarchist communities and it's no
surprise that over time as more people
move in
government becomes more and more
overbearing so i actually was thinking
about this in terms of science
and i feel like it's basically following
a similar principle to
the uh um the state of matter so i think
about it this way
you have gas particles are really are
far apart bouncing around all crazy and
so it makes this you know
gas can be you know moved and shifted
about and you can whiff through it and
all that stuff
as you start to compress that into a
tighter and tighter space becomes liquid
now it's harder to move through and then
if you compress it even further it
becomes a solid now you can't move
through it at all
that's basically how i view government
if you have a bunch of people all
separated
then they have these big bubbles of
inherent of personal freedom where they
can do whatever they want
we can go outside and launch our remote
control car 50 feet up in the air and
laugh as it smashes into the ground you
can't do that in new york
it'll come and get angry because the
closer people get together
it starts becoming rigid like solid
matter people's rights get compressed as
more people emerge around them
and then big cities start pushing
totalitarian and despotic
rules and laws can't have guns anymore
you can't play loud music
you can't you know play you can't play
play instruments in your own home
you you can't go out at certain points
oh no there's a pandemic now everyone's
gotta get shots everyone's gonna get
vaccine passports
then you go to the mountain where
everyone's separated life's normal
yeah make totally free we're also
unincorporated too
so we don't even have like that much
government
really i mean obviously we have like
state and county and stuff but
we don't i mean people will be in our
group chat being like hey is this legal
and people will respond and be like is
somebody gonna die
and then they'll be like no and they're
like okay then do it what are we like
uh like i mean that's that's that's so
we had a conversation about guns
uh with luke and we were talking about
how like in new york city for instance
it's like almost impossible to have a
gun
and then you get all these liberals
being like why would anyone need an
ar-15
and it's like you're not even saying
anything when you say that because
there's so many different variants and
like
calibers and modifications just like you
don't know what you're talking about
but i mentioned you know it's probably
not a good idea for someone to have
a 308 you know rifle
for home defense in a studio condo
in new york city because that bullet's
going to rip through
walls and maybe hit somebody and then
luke instinctively
said maybe we restrict and and i was
like
you can't you tread no no no the point
is
maybe the individual is responsible for
whatever comes out of the barrel of that
gun
and if they do have a 308 in their home
they should know better than firing it
because it's going to go through walls
and if they hit somebody that's
negligent homicide
because you are the individual
responsible for that weapon should be
allowed to have it but if you shoot it
you're going to get arrested when
someone gets hit or for the vandalism
and damage you caused by doing it
same as if you had a car and you drove
on a private property you're in trouble
so maybe favorite same if you had a car
and you were speeding and you hit
somebody you're legally allowed to have
a car you're not legally allowed to
crash that car into someone's storefront
so i'm like you know that that's the
idea of individual responsibility in big
cities
you can still have that freedom it's
just your responsibility i really like
this metaphor of
states of matter and government like
constriction like pressure like because
beyond so maybe we're in the fluidic
state it's either liquid or gas there's
resistance when you move
the government is the resistance you can
kind of push through it there's wind
resistance you hit terminal velocity
but once you get even more spacious than
gas you
turn into plasma which is the fourth
state of matter which is like
there is no wind resistance in a planet
people are running around firing rockets
and they're back
it's electromagnetic yeah what is it
like like plasma
is the fourth state of matter i would
liken that to living
literally in you know 100 square miles
of desert with no one around you
you could just take a dump right there
with access
like electrons can appear in different
places well okay no i don't know about
like matter formation i'm just talking
about the closer
people come together their rights start
compressing
and it becomes totalitarian like a rigid
solid state if you need to
import resources that's bringing people
closer together so
if you don't need to import resources
and you can create them on the spot
you could take a dump in the desert you
can create your water and your food the
fourth state
that's where we're headed the fourth
state of this analogy is that you're in
the middle of the woods
on this massive 200 acre plot of land
you own
and there's no one who's allowed on your
property and you take a dump right there
in an open field and the only one you
bothered is the guy in the space station
who's looking down with his you know
satellite telescope whatever and he's
like posting it to instagram you know
he's like that's so gross
or he laughs and he's like legit if
people could have lots of space and
could create all their materials on
on source like at on location i think
that we would not really need government
do it like this you could you could have
in the middle of nowhere
i mean there's so there still is
population density of the planet which
means you can't you know build nuclear
weapons and stuff because people
you'll interfere with them at a greater
distance but think about like
your range of effect when it comes to
your rights
if you live in a tiny cubicle apartment
in new york you can't play the drums man
because you're gonna have 10 people
being like dude come on man
it's not fair to us i know that first
hand right it's sad and so you're like i
have a right to be noisy
between these hours and it's true but
it's kind of a dick move you know people
might go to sleep they might have a
night shift
so it's not necessarily just about law
it's about social enforcement now you
live in the middle of nowhere 200 acres
you're right in the middle
you could literally pull out like i mean
just watch hickok45
the dude just goes nuts i watched the
video i was tweeting about the ksg25
dude loads ksg25 with slugs it's a
tactical shotgun that holds 25 shotgun
shells
and he's just going boom boom like crazy
just shooting shotgun slugs like nuts
because there's nobody around him and if
you had your own planet
you could set up nukes all over the
planet normally exactly that's the
plasma
you have your own planet like dr
manhattan and he builds a gigantic weird
structure and he floats around doing
whatever he wants because he got nothing
no one to bother and that's
literally you could light up nukes and
no one would care well let's let's
or it wouldn't be concerned let's jump
to a less
philosophical but uh interesting story
about someone bothering somebody
this is this is this is nuts you guys
ready for this nike sue's rapper lil nas
acts over satan shoes that have real
blood in the souls
the shoes which contain a drop of human
blood in the soil when on sale monday
for one thousand eighteen dollars per
pair
they say the shoes are unofficial
designs of nike's trademark air max 97
design
though the shoe companies that is not
involved with the creation of the shoe
they contain a drop of human blood in
the soul and when on sale monday
only 666 pairs were made available and
all were sold out shortly after going on
sale
the shoes drew plenty of high profile
critics including south dakota governor
christie gnome
and former clemson university
quarterback trevor lawrence our kids are
being told
this kind of product is not not only
okay
it's exclusive gnome tweeted the artist
responded by writing
you're a whole governor and you on here
tweeting about some damn shoes do your
job
lil nice axe is not named a defendant in
nike's lawsuit
not named interesting shortly after the
lawsuit was announced he posted a tweet
showing a homeless
squidward from spongebob squarepants
begging for change
and it says me after the nike lawsuit
and there's a homeless squidward
i thought that was funny i thought that
was funny
nike filed a trademark infringement and
delusion complaint against
ms ch mischief ms mschf today
related to satan's shoes quote we don't
have further details to share on pending
legal matters however we can tell you we
do not have a relationship with lil nos
x or mischief
the satan's shoes were produced without
nike's approval or authorization
and nike is in no way connected with
this project
first of all that tweet with the
squidward thing that was legit that was
funny
uh how did he decide like how did how
was he able to make a nike shoe
without nike's approval that's that's
just not they're customs they're not
actually by nike but isn't that
infringement of some sort like you would
think but it seems like they
i mean there's a huge culture i've been
learning this last two days because i'm
in a twitter world
nazas fans right now but i got ratioed
to hell
myself but uh um
there's this like huge subculture of
people who customize
sneakers and apparently it's a really
big deal and nike normally doesn't
enforce copyright
i guess but because this one has caused
so
much blow back i think they had no
choice really
i don't care about this shoe this i
actually think it's kind of funny he
dripped blood in the shoes and then
resold them is that what it is
i think it's his blood i really want to
know whose blood it is
i mean look i think it's weird but i
think if somebody wants to make a weird
shoe and sell it and they like
oh i'm saying yeah but whatever it had
the nike design on it the logo yeah okay
my issue with it is not the troll game
like i respect his troll game he's
he got me ratioed real hard like i got
ratio
to hell like it was crazy i
i have to give him props for that at
least
you know troll respects troll i guess
[Laughter]
but um my only issue with anything that
he's done
is the fact that in january he was doing
interviews with npr
bragging about how children are his fan
base
he was doing videos with elmo he wrote a
children's book
he performed in an elementary school gym
like he i think there was a kids bop
version of
country roads or whatever the song is
called i mean
he he really went out of his way to
market to children which is a smart
thing to do because children are a huge
consumer base
and parents are going to spend money on
their kids all the time and
yeah it's all smart i think he i think
i'm glad he did
but the problem is you can't brand
yourself
i mean i think that the lyrics to old
town wrote are questionable anyway and
parents
probably shouldn't have been letting
their kids listen to it but you know
after the children's book and the npr
interview and
during concert in roblox he's branded
himself as somebody that is safe for
children
so this is the best thing he could have
done with the satan shoe with the blood
in it
because now parents are going to be like
whoa maybe i shouldn't have my kid
following this if they catch it on time
i mean as a parent
i have a really difficult time with it
because my daughter wants to watch
people playing video games and stuff
and so she'll i'll be watching a video
game channel with her
and it'll seem very wholesome and it'll
be great for weeks
and then all of a sudden they'll start
talking about like some
insane cult blue and on nonsense or
you know saying that there's 170 genders
or whatever the hell
and and it's hard to keep up with it
especially on youtube and stuff like
that but even with like disney channel
and nickelodeon
it's very hard right now to find like
wholesome content that you can trust and
i
and i know parents work and there's all
kinds of stuff going on you can't always
keep up
this guy built a reputation that he was
safe for children
and then he came out with a video where
he's pole dancing to hell
and then giving a lap dance to satan
you can't really blame parents for being
upset with this one
i'm just saying by doing this and
generating the controversy
it's like sending a flare up into the
air so that parents can see it and maybe
now realize he's not so safe for kids
right which is why people are calling it
out right everybody's like you're trying
to get them canceled and
you know all this stuff and first it's
like yeah kind of because like i firmly
believe that we should be canceling the
left back
but also it's more about
making sure that parents see it you want
parents to know not to let their kids
watch this
and so by putting articles up on gateway
pundit that are getting you know
hundreds of thousands of views
maybe some parents will be like oh crap
my kid really likes this i better watch
out
absolutely and and i think that's
important it kind of reminds me of i
think it's
i think it's a family guy joke where
they give you know one of the kids like
stewie
a children's video on youtube and
they're like hi kids let's learn the
abcs
and then like the parent walks away and
they're like abc all right your parents
gone good going to mommy's
purse get her credit card now go to this
website yeah yeah it's like are they
gone all right let's do this
there's a lot of jokes like that i just
think i mean for one again i'll stress
his troll game's on point and so i look
at what he's doing as like screwing the
status quo it's punk
rock man and i was i was thinking about
that like where's
where's the you know we we talked about
eminem's
song cancel me or something i think it's
called i don't know without me
no no no no it's like a new one you're
trying to i think he's so dorky
yeah it's not very good but we talked
about that song without me
uh you guys remember that song i love
that from like 2002.
the whole song makes no sense oh right
now
without giving me a minute it's called
without me
yeah and the whole song is about
cultural references at the time
he's literally just talking smack and
being extremely offensive
i don't think anybody would make
anything like that and popularize it on
tv or in movies the way they did because
he literally makes
disparaging remarks about christina
aguilera you know surfacing
two guys from that era in the song and
that song's got a billion views
i'm just thinking about this stuff like
where are the people who are like i'm
going to screw with the system to like
my utmost
like the to the maximum possible level
and just tell everyone to go shove it
you can't do anything about it
i mean this isn't new though we had
marilyn manson we've had all this stuff
before it's not new
it's just the only thing that's
different is yeah he look this is
literally two months ago
it's not like we're talking about like
miley cyrus where she was a child star
and then grew up and started making
content that was more geared for adults
i know people still get mad about that
but that bothers me less
this was literally in january he's
putting out children's books he's going
on npr
talking about how he wants to appeal to
children or how he
likes that he appeals to children and it
was a marketing strategy
children are a huge huge product
consumer base like what how old of
children
i mean the average age for roblox
concert is
under 13 like the average roblox users
under 13 my daughter uses it all the
time um
he did a video with elmo i mean that's
geared towards
toddlers sesame street went like full on
racist apparently anyway so elmo
elmo got to learn about why martin
luther king jr was wrong and one of the
weirdest segments i've ever seen sesame
street do it's amazing
yeah so uh sesame street introduces two
new black puppets
abcs of racial literacy and apparently
these characters are saying like the
color of their skin is a very important
aspect of who they are
all right fine i'm being a bit
hyperbolic when i say they they learn
about why my thing was wrong it's not
literally what they're saying
i'm sure martin luther king jr thought
there was relevancy to the color of skin
because of racism
they say first revealed on march 24th by
sesame workshop
the non-profit organization responsible
for the long-running children's show
production abc's of racial literacy
resource
is designed to help families celebrate
their own unique identities
and answer children's tough questions
about race and racism
apparently in this like sesame street
segment
he asks them why they're like black and
they explain their race and all that
stuff
the issue i take with it is that while i
certainly think color blindness as a
general term
is probably not a good thing we do want
to recognize racism exists and that
people are treated poorly
you want to treat people as equals
without consideration of their race
the problem is i guess many people are
saying no you should give me positive
discrimination
because of past discrimination that's
ibro max kennedy's like thought process
so sure this dude's doing videos with
elmo i'm not sure elmo or something
people want to have their kids watch
but you know what happens i bet a lot of
millennial parents are like i used to
watch sesame street
you should watch sesame street too and
their kid comes in one day one day like
a seven-year-old goes to their mom
and starts preaching about racial
segregation and the mom's going to be
like what
and it's just happened to me like
recently and it's shocking like i
am almost a helicopter parent about what
my daughter sees
what she does on the internet i don't
allow her to be on the internet if i'm
not in the room
like i am kind of kind of a bit much
about this
but but i was watching we went on
vacation we don't have cable at my house
we just watched like streaming services
but we're on vacation we're in the hotel
room and i put on the disney channel
and we're just watching a show that
we've watched a million times old show
so it's not
you know over the top but a commercial
came on talking about like the
impeachment and how
he's not necessary just because he was
found not guilty doesn't mean he didn't
do something wrong
and then black lives matter commercials
and all this stuff and i'm sitting there
i'm like
when i was little disney it was
wholesome as heck like and so i
i implicitly like i trust disney channel
and nickelodeon and stuff because when i
was a kid it was like people getting
slimed and stuff
they weren't talking about politics they
weren't talking about this stuff wow
when i was a kid all that stuff i wanted
to do the opposite of
you know what i mean like when we would
see those commercials about like
well at least maybe it's growing up in
the south side of chicago where they're
like you know stay out of gangs kids and
don't do drugs like all of my friends
were like
hmm i think i'm gonna go do those things
what are those yeah what are those
yeah apparently there was like i guess
in some instances the dare program which
was telling kids not to do drugs
just taught them how to do drugs it's
like don't put it in your mouth and
light it with a lighter and then
suck it in don't do that don't inhale
afterwards
yeah so we just watched uh man of the
year just like as aside
as an aside real quick have you seen men
of the year no 2006 robin williams
so andreas was telling us he's a dude
who hangs out here
uh he was telling us that there's a
scene where robin williams says kofi
kofi over and over again he doesn't
but we watched the film it's about a
media personality supposed to be like
jon stewart
and people are like why don't you run
for president he does and then he wins
it's the craziest thing you got to watch
it you got to see us you know why
you know why you got to watch it no it
was like watching someone predicted
donald trump
robin williams plays a misogynistic
anti-semitic
comedian and i don't mean that in the
literal sense i mean that at the time
that comedy was considered
appropriate and good and everyone loved
it on the left
so when he makes jokes about women and
jews and illegal aliens
everyone's laughing and so he actually
says he gets like 10
in the polls there's one scene where
basically
he's debating the other two presidents
because his poll numbers are so well
and then he's like they want to add a
constitutional amendment so you can't
burn the american flag
it's a distraction because four million
illegal aliens just crossed our border
robin williams said that wow and i was
like this is crazy and then
he ends up winning i'm gonna spoil the
movie it's you know 20 years old but he
ends up winning because of a computer
glitch
so new electronic voting machines are
brought in
and there's a glitch which causes him to
win it's the weirdest thing
ever just like watching this movie now
the weird the craziest thing about it is
it ends with like he wins the presidency
then it ends with him realizing he
didn't really win he goes on saturday
night live and he's like
the establishment should be in charge we
should allow the political elites
who have no allegiance to the american
people but like he says it seriously
the whole point of the movie is him
saying the republican party the
democratic party represents us anymore
that they're just in it for the special
interest to take all this money then
they owe favors these to these interests
and they pay him back
by screwing over the little guy and
ignoring what the people need and at the
end he's like
but you know what maybe that's how it
should be and then they all cheer and
celebrate and center it live is like yay
it's really it's a really creepy movie
wow super creepy
yeah just you should check it out anyway
let's go to super chats my friends if
you have not already
smash that like button because it really
really does help crush it
don't forget to subscribe hit that
notification bell and go to timcast.com
become a member we are actually
um we're going through the hiring
process for a few people we've already
brought in some people
and we're going to be hiring writers
we're going to start doing articles
we're going to have legit fact checking
all this really great stuff and we're
going to be doing new shows so cassandra
and i are planning a
cult paranormal weird and wild we just
gotta
figure out how to get it going and then
we'll get it going but like you know
these are these are things that are that
are all happening
the difficulty is we got to bring on
people to do administrative production
positions so they can oversee these
projects because i i can't literally do
everything there's only so many hours a
day
but become a member because when you
sign up for timcast.com not only
do you get access to these amazing bonus
segments that we'll do and we'll have
one tonight
you are helping to fund the creation of
new content
and i just like we want to make fun
shows and stuff it's just not woke and
it'll be original
independent slightly lower budget but
done well i'll put it that way
all right smash that like button and
let's get to these super chats
also don't forget we got that really
great um
uh diamond hands gorilla shirts
available you can see in the chat and at
timecast.com go to shop
so uh the first super chat which for
some reason youtube always cuts the name
off i don't know why
they mentioned the astrazeneca vaccine i
believe that's the one that's been disc
that's been put on
frozen in canada that's the one yeah
matthew hammond says cassandra is the
best
can she host the podcast cults
conspiracies in cassandra what are you
waiting for tim
uh administrative support so like
production
to like oversee the project but uh yeah
how about cult conspiracies with
cassandra
triple c pretty good yeah and thank you
all right i'm very excited to do it mark
hunt says what's your thoughts on the
suez canal situation
i love the memes there was one post
where someone said
every man on the planet has a solution
to how to get the ship
unstuck it's like all of the men of the
world stan standing around a pickle jar
that needs to be unstuck and they're
telling you how to do it
and then the best with the response was
and each and every one of their
responses is correct
yes yes uh they they got it unstuck
the [ __ ] and then ten minutes later i
got stuck again oh wow but i guess they
got it back out
oh good it's funny okay so that was
costing
it was a ship ran aground in the sewers
canal blockaded and was costing like
60 million dollars a minute or some some
absorbent amount of lost
uh transit so there's a bunch of memes
where it's like
you know i think luke posted ordered
nine millimeter
and then it was like shipping it was
like it was en route and the guy like
smiling and then it says
uh last known location suez canal and
he's like i'm shocked
yup well not it's not that it's in the
canal that nothing could get through the
canal
all right let's see cryptic says tim how
do you feel about the rising wall street
silver movement
some mints are now unable to deliver
silver to unallocated accounts until
months
looks like the physical squeeze on
silver is working
that'll be really interesting i mean i
don't know enough about silver how
that's going to work
i do own silver i mean i think most
people have some kind of silver
uh it'll be cool i don't know i don't
know if it's good or bad i don't know
about it i should say that 20 million a
minute i don't know if that's what was
going to be lost in the suez canal yeah
what do you think about silver the
athenians mind it that's what made
athens so great
silver yeah silver mine what'd they do
with it um
melted into coins primarily uh i don't
know what else but
they would just use slaves people would
like lease their slaves to the athenian
state to go down there mine silver
robin cosby says astrazeneca covet
vaccine is the blood clot one that
everyone is worried about
well there's all there's alternatives
you know eric allen says thanks for
clearing up friday for people
it definitely helps and i hope you guys
collab again soon much love
legit it was our fault um i didn't
communicate with jeremy beforehand
and then he ended up going on adam's
show and so then when i came up for
pre-production
what people need to understand is uh for
a lot of guests when they come in here
and i haven't talked to them before
there's always something we can just
talk about so you'll notice some shows
are literally
like when we had jody shaw on she for i
think for like 40 minutes she was just
telling her story we didn't need a lot
of pre-production to be like tell me
your story let's work our way through
this
for jeremy we both do a very similar you
know kind of commentary thing and we had
just done a show the night before
so we kind of exhausted a lot of the
topics we could have talked about and
then he didn't realize we had an earlier
call time because
it's our fault someone on our end told
him not to worry about it
and then i was like dude i don't we
don't have any stories like i've not
prepared anything we haven't gone over
anything we haven't talked about
anything
and a lot of stuff we were gonna talk
about we talked about yesterday i was
like i just don't know if i have an
enemy to like puts pulsing together in
the last few minutes
and so it was it was my fault nothing to
do with jeremy
he was uh he did everything he was
supposed to be jeremy you are the man
too i hope you're watching i love you
dude and
thanks for coming that was really fun
and um we should play games someday
i know it's a little i'm scared of if uh
over the internet but um
let's hang out sometime come back or
i'll go over your house yeah
some people mentioned like with james
o'keefe he was super late
and i'll i'll mention with james
straight up when when he called me
before the show and said i'm going to be
late i was like i can't do it bro i was
like look we try to be on time for
everybody
and if you can't make it like i'm i just
i don't like i don't play favorites with
people
i've had so many really amazing
high-profile people message me saying
just do a remote show tim
just for me and i'm like dude i can't do
it because i'm not going to do a special
thing for every single person
james chartered a private plane and so i
was like
oh okay i was like all right dude okay
you got it
so and that and that also too was very
much james says don't worry i've got a
bunch of stuff to talk about so when i
get there i was like okay i guess we'll
try and you know put something together
and then when he gets here he's just
going to talk to us we ended up doing a
full hour bonus show
because there was so much james and i
hadn't talked about it's really really
hard i think people need to understand
too
that there's a lot there's a decent
amount of pre-production it's not the
biggest deal in the world but it's a
decent amount where we warm up we talk
about ideas
we line up our stories you'll notice we
pull up a bunch of stories and read
through them because we did all the work
loading them in the first place
so maybe not the what people expected
but that's just the reality
and uh sometimes it's just hard to pull
things together and we screw
up it's just a sad reality i guess
let's see colby locks production says
what happened to the right to privacy or
patient confidentiality from doctors
businesses and government
doesn't need to know my medical history
let alone what i do in my private life
at home
that's actually a really really
important point
hipaa laws yeah right what if i just say
i don't have to prove it because my
privacy we give them an inch and they're
going to take a mile
that's my fear with all of it well nazis
would like really they would execute
sick people that was a big part of it he
wanted to get rid of like the the not
pure people and a lot of those were like
people that have mental problems or
physical
you know problems or just illness in
general i have a question
was it with the americans with
disabilities act is what it's called
yeah
so what if you go to walmart and they're
like you have to have proof of vaccine
and you say
i have allergies i can't get it can they
say you're not allowed to come to this
business because of a medical condition
i wonder if they'll do exemption cards
i've dealt with severe allergy before
when i was growing up
it freaks me out i was in the hospital
like for a couple days i think it could
kill you
yeah it's no joke that's why people
carry epipens and so when they announced
they're like
vaccine don't take it if you're if you
have food allergies you got to wait i'm
like
you got it because i've i've been
through that i do not want to go through
that again
so what am i supposed to do if they
launch these passports look i think
vaccines are rad but
i was advised against you know and it's
not even it's not even any particular
vaccine
i was reading about it and they said for
most new vaccines there's a wait period
for people with food allergies because
there's the possibility of a
anaphylactic reaction and then we saw
those nurses who had it
so i'm just like dude apparently those
nurses were like no it's okay i'm fine i
was treated i'm like yeah but
like going to the er and like getting
the epinephrine like i'm not all about
that man
sorry like if people you know
i want to get it like i got no beef i'm
stoked
look i know a lot of people are saying
they're worried about it being rushed
but i'm like
trump's the one who who rushed this
through i don't think i don't trust
trump with everything either
he didn't even pardon assange that's
true especially
i i i don't know trump is wonderful he's
great and all but
just because he pushed it doesn't mean
that it's great i i'm sorry i
can't get on board i i'm gonna get us in
trouble if i keep talking
i just i just think that i i think
they didn't want to give him a success
you know what i mean i i think
fda approval is extremely important a
lot of these vaccines
have been around for a really really
long time so you know the adverse
effects
so i really just i'm not i
i don't know i just think we need fda
approval people who are very
high risk should take it i just think
exactly that the risk
for people who are not high risk is
too questionable i don't want a food
allergy at risk the fda
is not even the end-all it's just an
organization like they say aspartame is
totally fine
because they've done one study on rats
with it that caused
cancer or or seemed like it was
carcinogenic but because they never did
other studies on aspartame they say
there aren't enough studies
to say that it's 100 percent sure about
all of those fats
yes i've studied that yeah last i've
studied they did one one aspartame study
carcinogen study on rats and then it
showed that there was
a likelihood that it was carcinogenic
and then they stopped doing the studies
and now they say there aren't enough
studies to prove it so well
not enough evidence i think cultural
enforcement social enforcement is always
the most important thing
you know that people don't drink that
stuff a lot as much anymore like soda
regular old soda people don't like
drinking that anymore water consumption
is going up so great we got the you know
you ever see hydro homies on reddit
there's a there's a viral reddit group
where it's just people like
gotta drink more water and they post
pictures of bottled water and that's
like
means about drinking more water yeah i
was reading that like soda consumption
is way way down
wow i know all my friends when we go out
to eat we usually just get like water
or alcohol if you get alcohol but when
it comes like fasted restaurants most
people go to fast food restaurants don't
get
large sodas anymore does it necessarily
look like unsweet tea or something
called nestle on coca-cola
especially coca-cola um i wonder if
they're investing in water like doing
bottled water at least avion is like
oh of course they are absolutely so
they're like let's get away from soda
let's buy the water mines
and then we'll start selling water
instead which has a double-edged sword i
guess
all right let's read this from brent
saigan he says hey tim you're bullying
of my brother grant to make an account
on your website as yet to work
but could you shout out my friend robert
he listens to some of your stuff and
he's leaving for the navy today
oh wow sounds rad uh cool man
well have fun absolutely and thanks for
listening to the show
and your your brother grant darn it
grant he's letting us down
i think if grant doesn't sign up i might
have to pack it in because to be honest
i was just trying to get his respect the
whole time
disappointed grant what's up dude if i
can't inspire you then maybe i should
just take the beanie off
you can inspire come on grant you can
join
become a member at timcast.com
joe spinella says the privileges and
immunities clause u.s constitutional
u.s constitution article 4 section 2
clause 1
also knows as the comedy clause prevents
a state from treating citizens of other
states in a discriminatory manner so
that means new york can't really do what
they're doing with this vaccine passport
huh
that's weird i don't know i'll look that
up it's going to require a
supreme court lawsuit i feel like the
government's doing a whole lot of things
that they shouldn't be able to do
so i don't even know anymore urgency
yeah yeah
they often and yep i mean we're still
dealing with the patriot
act and stuff i mean we're going to be
dealing with these covet emergency
things for a long time i think
so uh nishra produces uh some of some of
my music and you know
uh many people many people many people
probably know her from adam's show
which i remember she asked a few months
ago she was like we're talking about
guns and she's she's from sweden she
goes wait a minute i'm confused the
second amendment says
the right to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed and we all go uh-huh
but they're infringing and we all start
laughing like yes yes
she's so cool yes she mentioned this to
me before she was like just earlier
today she was like i don't understand
how your constitution literally says you
can't do it
but like everywhere does it and i'm like
you're asking me dude that's my thing
it's like
i actually think we should be
responsible and have a conversation
about
gun control but i think the constitution
says otherwise
and if people want to change that
doesn't matter what my opinion is or
anyone else's
there it is constitution says it then
you got to bring all the states together
and change it
and that's the reality of how it's
supposed to work yeah it's free
everywhere and then state by state they
can kind of dictate but then city by
city
can they do it also can they be like in
this city it's open carry even if the
state says no
apparently there's a bunch of rulings
already saying everything they do is
illegal anyway
but who wants to be the person to get
standing to sue after they get arrested
or charged i think the nra
or someone like that the nra are they
like in the pocket of somebody
the nra is just like a i don't know
that's kind of their i don't what do
they do isn't their purpose to uphold
gun rights
they don't yeah but that's their purpose
is to collect donations
gun owners is really good though as an
alternative to nra i really like them
they actually stood up for um the
controversial person in kenosha um i i
want i want some gun rights
organizations to go to
the inner city youth in chicago who are
arrested on gun possession charges
and advocate for their right to keep and
bear arms that's pretty cool i'm
actually looking right now
west virginia just passed something
pretty cool but i don't want to misstate
it
and i'm sorry that i keep talking what
do you think it is
um you are legally obligated to carry a
gun no there's some
something they're they're gonna not
um enforce federal laws
oh interesting about guns but i i don't
want to misstate it
yeah well there's always the atf so yeah
all right let's see karis says hey tim i
work in healthcare i install patient
monitoring
hardware and software i work with nurses
doctors and biomed personnel
sometimes a mask is our only armor in
these hospitals
like that rare charm in an rpg yes yeah
man
people don't realize about this hospital
people don't realize this about
hospitals but old people
die from hospitals yes no joke they'll
get sick or they'll have to go to the
hospital for a broken bone
and then there's just illness all over
the hospital people are sick
and so they can contract the stuff what
like you know mrsa and stuff
yes yes all right let's see
i found it west virginia house passes
bill to ban
enforcement of federal gun control past
present and future
wow wow so i mean they'll still have to
go to justice and stuff but
right right obviously and you still got
to deal with the atf yeah so we got the
federal government
but we've had a lot of counties in west
virginia becoming sanctuary counties too
yeah and they're saying that they won't
work with atf they won't work with fbi
or whatever
so yeah but that means so what
so it'll be interesting to see what
happens if someone in west virginia
decides to
get a full auto weapon without going
through the nfa
the tax and all that stuff in the atf
we'll see they're not going to have help
from local law enforcement if
if you know things go as they look like
they're going to
but then this could lead to a lawsuit
that goes to the supreme court yeah
all gun control is racist and i'm not
even exaggerating that's true
ask maj toure and black guns matter
about it because they're not wrong
all right landon says hey tim and chrome
a soldier in the us army our unit has
had loose rules regarding the wearing of
the mask since the lockdown began
but other units are very strict about
the mask it all depends on who your
leaders are
interesting darth typhan says tim you
guys should
have magnus pen vidya on the show it
would make for a great conversation
regarding the culture war between the
establishment
and bottom unity groups such as boogs
anti-fascists and right-wing militias
keep up the great work
thank you very much
storm skip says tim can you talk about
how democrat policies fit together
lockdowns cause people to lose jobs so
they can't afford the reintroduced
individual mandate of aca
soon they need to go on government
health care to get a vaccine passport
that's really interesting did they
reintroduce the individual mandate
the in the involuntary mandate
ben walker says thanks for talking
seriously about vaccine risks
i'm 100 pro-vaxx but side effects can be
serious
check out pandemics gsk swine flu
vaccine that gave over 10 people
narcolepsy
i have narcolepsy it's no joke provacs
but people should be aware of potential
risks
i think that's in an honest society we'd
be saying dude vaccines are amazing
they're amazing
i had a conversation with uh some
conspiracy person a while ago and i said
if you've got you know a million people
who might die from something
so you introduce a vaccine that's going
to save 950 000
and then 50 000 people will will get
some serious side effect from the
vaccine some resulting in death
but you saved 950 000 people like the
problem i think a lot of people don't
realize is that
if there is a system in place that
causes some adverse effect
they focus on that as the worst possible
thing when it's possible
covet could have been way worse so one
of the challenges with talking about
lockdowns and masks and all this
is that we have no metric by which to
judge a lot of these policies
because we all did it you can look at
sweden
you can look at the numbers in texas and
we start to get a clear picture of okay
maybe lockdowns were a bad idea
in the beginning though we just didn't
know there was nothing to compare it to
so we were like let's try and do the
right thing and then when people were
looking at numbers
we still didn't know maybe it would have
been worse if we didn't we don't know
now it's a year plus on now we're
starting to get a better picture
tax is the numbers going down in florida
they're well below average because it
return it turns out covet actually
transmits easier indoors i guess that's
what fauci was saying
and now we're kind of changing that
policy for some reason biden wants to
keep going
i think it's because safety is easier
just to absolve themselves a
responsibility
of course but if you give up freedom for
safety you lose both and deserve neither
according to one of the great founding
fathers all right steve smithy says hey
tim love the show are you excited for
the new hearthstone expansion
what class are you looking forward to
playing the most also if you like card
games you should check
out this upcoming game called the
bizarre um that's super i don't i don't
i used to be way more into hearthstone i
don't care too much or track the
expansions or anything like that
but i do play a lot i typically just
play the tavern brawls and the solo
because
eh it's more fun it's just more fun
great youtuber called trump
that uh does hearthstone videos which
twitch i watch a lot of trump
um mage mages mages
i like warlock because of the draw yeah
it's slow
it's it's just so op the mage getting
that point of damage every turn
just spot removal you know what i mean
nature is insane
it's blizzard's blizzard's card game
it's awesome it's like a world a
warcraft card game
nice all right so bass says desantis is
already planning an executive order
banning vaccine passports in florida
i need to leave new jersey yes sir you
need to leave new jersey we left quite a
while we left a little while ago only
several months at this point it's been
it's been
just about half a year or so not quite
and uh
yes this is why luke went to florida
luke went to florida because of desantis
i'm assuming
desantis is like we're going to protect
people from censorship
we're we're going to allow people to be
open and live normally and luke was like
you can buy guns you can go to the beach
you can go to the restaurants and eat
food like normal
censorship desantis is doing a good job
it's
i'm like i want to love desantis so bad
but he's
actually not really great on censorship
um he was very i think he actually
signed a bill
in israel um that was
um in israel yeah it's about bds oh
and as much as i hate the left and they
make me crazy
i i think that censoring bds what is bds
uh boycott divest and sanctions
a lot of people are advocating for it
and then some a lot of groups have tried
to like
ban it in some capacity like didn't
congress try to ban it or something well
they try
to make sure the agencies who support it
don't get
government money i believe i i could be
wrong i'm not
super well versed on it but i really
oppose
any um like government mandates on who
you can boycott or not and i think that
that's a
very strange and
dangerous form of censorship so i don't
like it
it's really simple i oppose blocking
contracts with companies that engage in
any capacity in bds because they're
calling for
boycotting divesting or sanctioning
israel i don't agree with bds
but they're expressing their political
views and their opinions i do agree
with donald trump's executive order
banning government contracts with
companies that engage in critical race
theory
because the critical race theory
trainings are a violation of the 1964
civil rights act i believe title vii
it's a big difference bds is here's my
opinion and here's what i think we
should do and so we're going to hold
this ourselves to this
and the other companies are like we're
engaging in illegal practices also it's
a foreign nation
like you're boycotting a foreign nation
it's not like you're doing
something that has any effect on
american companies or
i i don't know it just it's weird to me
to legislate that americans
can't speak out against another very
strange it
right and i mean i know the the right a
lot of the right really supports it
but like for me that is a thing every
time that i'm like yeah desantis you're
killing it you're doing great i
i think about that and i'm just like
that's real
it nags at me it's like yup you got to
be careful for tribalism
yeah because they might just be doing
things that are popular with the base
yeah
all right patrick says as a proud
mountaineer i've been very happy with
how my state has handled coven
the election and the bills being put
through the legislature right now
yeah me too they're so good i've been
watching it all day
my whole feed is like cheering for
various things that west virginia has
passed the dallas dead eye says tim is
like don't believe fake news media but
bet your life on medical media because
they don't lie foolish you see that is
just a gross mischaracterization of my
opinions
here's what i actually think a good
portion of
vc funded digital media outlets is woke
rage bait garbage
this stuff has begun infecting a bunch
of major corporate news outlets like cnn
the new york times
many of these outlets do report very
fine news
but i have to sift through it to try and
figure out what's garbled nonsense and
what's actually backed up and even i
can't do that all the time
so i actually don't say you know
i'll definitely say question a lot of
the stories from the media and fact
check them
but i use cnn the new york times for
various stories and i use them on
purpose
because i'm not saying everything they
do is bad i'm saying they have very
the corrupt components within them as
for the medical media
let me tell you this doctors used to
tell you to smoke
they're not always right and there are
risks involved in any of these things
but i'll put it this way man i've gotten
tons of vaccines
i understand this is rushed i understand
people are are taking serious issue with
it
i understand canada has just suspended
the astrazeneca vaccine
european countries it's something
similar there are real conversations
happening around whether or not
they're going to be serious risks and
long-term effects my point is that
i think you you said it best the older
people who are at risk should get it
younger people probably don't need it
and i'll put it this way when it comes
to vaccines
i go to the doctor and the doctor says
frozen
dazzaban and not nazopreen or whatever
and i'm like i don't know dude i have no
idea what that is i'll google it and be
like i don't know what am i supposed to
do
patch me up doc and send me on my way
talk to your doctor
and i got to be honest you should be
trusting your doctor more than you trust
me or
anybody else your doctor who you talk to
talk to is going to know about your
health more than dr fauci or trump or me
or joe biden or anybody that's all that
really matters man
i kind of take a view of like skepticism
with any kind of media but also not
obtrusivism like don't just
reject it at face value just because it
comes from the media or the
pharmaceutical industry
including these like i was just looking
up some aspartame studies there was one
about rats in 2006. you looked it up
yeah
that caused cancer they said there were
problems with the study they say they've
done more studies on it never really
found a link
you know that's how i live i'm skeptical
i got to do my own research really and
read each study piece by piece
yeah myself says tim i had a dream that
you hosted an event at your compound and
we went turkey hunting on your property
you see a lot of turkeys out there been
practicing your calls
we have a lot of turkeys the other day
we had a group of turkeys just walking
through the parking lot
and they're just doing turkey stuff
they're chunked dude uh we're not gonna
kill them though
nice yeah so i was asked by the guys at
the gun shop they were like you got a
lot of turkeys i was like oh one day we
probably like 20 or 30.
and they were like come on no no
no we're like you know we're not going
to kill it it made me think about
andreas was telling me in the sauna the
other day
we have a son by the way and it's
amazing get in the sauna if you can
um that if you play bat sounds did he
tell you this i was like how do we get
rid of the mosquitoes he's like you play
bat sounds
mosquitoes are true they know that sound
he said he went into a room in south
america that was like
infested with like thousands of
mosquitoes like it was disgusting
and they played bat sounds on their
phone and they all left all the
mosquitoes left the room
because yeah
we got chickens uh sad news though i
tweeted about it
um we did we did lose two of the
chickens and the sad truth is that they
were just
weak you know we talked to we went to a
local farm we got some uh we got eight
chickens and they were all fairly young
i think they were like five
weeks old and very quickly two of them
started getting sick and displaying
signs of parasites
one of them just dropped dead and it was
like rather abrupt we knew it was sick
and i didn't i was like i don't know
what to do i googled it
and then within like 16 hours of
realizing i was sick it was just
it just collapsed i went out one morning
and it was just standing there all
poofed up and chilling
came back an hour later and it was
collapsed it was struggling to breathe
and then within 20 minutes
gone the next one was was really sad it
was a really nice little chicken
and it was active we got brought to the
vet
the vet said looks like a parasite we're
gonna give it some medicine we did
and then we started on medicine for the
first day
and then all of a sudden started
improving she started drinking water
started eating food
and peeping and i was like this is
fantastic next morning dead
just wow yeah just gone another of our
chickens
started poofing up stopped you start
getting lethargic and i was like oh man
because they're
they're spreading this parasite so i
gave it the medicine at the first sign
later in the day chicken was running
around eating again next day i gave a
medicine
seems to be totally fine now
because there might be still trace
parasites they basically poop in their
own food and then pick at it
they're such nasty little filthy filthy
little dinosaurs watching
watching these little things walk up to
their water drink and then turn around
and just lift their wings and just
dump right in their water i'm like oh
god how are you doing
i got to clean it out wow and they're
still alive
but they've the species has we got we
got stink bugs here like crazy
like nobody's business chickens love
they'll eat right out of your hands too
and it doesn't hurt they'll peck at your
fingers doesn't hurt but you give them a
stink bug and they all start chasing
each other
fighting over it yeah i want to do like
a chicken race where like one of them
has a stink bug and you just have it
like a long
corridor that they run the other ones
they're great they're getting big real
fast i'm excited
yeah right right now they're in chicken
college in the chicken city because they
all hang out together and like huddle
together no marxism though and then
yeah there's no marxism that's very
capitalistic and then once they're older
there's houses they'll have to you know
move into their own homes
no critical chicken theory yeah
we're watching though to see if it
displays naturally yeah
it won't clayton pajunus says hey guys
i just want to say thanks and share some
attendees hopefully my diamond hands
gorilla shirt come soon
p.s ian's killing today love y'all oh
yeah there you go i'm excited for you to
get your shirt
yeah we uh we got we got them they're
downstairs we need to open up oh nice
i'll wear one
tomorrow maybe yeah the diamond hands
gorilla so most of you know we have the
i am a gorilla shirt it's just a meme
about
alex jones when he kept saying he was a
gorilla so we made a gorilla saying
amarilla
means nothing else really but then
because there was the meme from the wall
street vets about
apes strong together the planet of the
apes thing and they used the gorilla
emoji i was like let's give our gorilla
a suit
and hold stacks of cash with a cigar and
sunglasses
so it's the diamond hands girl see he's
got all this cash because he has diamond
hands and he held
for as long as possible and then he sold
out at the top
or i guess diamond hands means you never
sell wow i don't know i haven't sold i
still have a bunch of i love it a bunch
of amy's
if it were me i'd keep it forever why
not i mean earth
arceon says to both ian and tim you guys
need to do more research on the council
of nicaea
if you know anything about the history
of catholicism you would know that
gnostic bibles were made to subvert
christianity narcissism came hundreds of
years after christ
constant protected the bible's
legitimacy interesting
i think the palace of gnosis was a a
[ __ ] a minoan
capital it was it was k-n-o-s-s-i-s not
gnostus gnosis i don't know if they were
related seemed like a learning a
learning place but sheamus will be here
uh eventually and he is a master of
catholicism yeah he knows
we could definitely talk about that that
would be fun stephen
pizzowski says i live in richmond va
cassandra is right
broad street which was the best it's
been in 50 years is still mostly boarded
up from the riots
i work in government small business
small business applications are down 90
percent
i was right where the riots were and in
the stonewall jackson
statue we drove past that and stuff and
i was just like
it's not the richmond that you think of
anymore
it was very odd and yeah you could see
all the riot stuff left over is horrible
crazy yeah dixon says ian is
soy moses and i'm here just to watch him
take red pills i will feed you the
golden calf
[Laughter]
you can eat gold monatomic or colloidal
gold suspended in water if you go online
and look for it
and it's really good for you it coats
the neurons in your brain
causes them to super conduct if you're
stretching and your muscle's going to
rip it'll fill in the rip and you can
don't take medical advice this is not
medical advice
it's a supplement it's like a food but
apparently gold used to be in the ground
and we would get trace like you want
iron in your body you want like vitamin
c
from dirt too and we mine so much of it
out that we're not getting enough gold
in our diets so you supplement
interesting that moses
moses would have been into that all
right dr doctor says a man who is
truthful to himself has no secrets and
tells no lies has nothing to
to fear but himself also change starts
from within and flows outwards
thank you to all for all uh thank you to
all
for being self-actualized you're helping
others find their way and voice much
love
appreciate it nice thank you hayden says
the terrifying cult isn't actually
marxist it's traditionalists with a
capital t
look into professor benjamin
teitelbaum's work on the subject
greenwald is a fan this was the viking
aim of ragnarok the utopian goal of the
germans in 1930s and others
yeah the the woke left are not
progressives in the actual literal
definition
they're very much reactionaries in the
literal definition
so reactionaries were those who wanted
to maintain the status quo in the french
revolution
simplifying for sure and they'll call
themselves progressives today
because they know it's the only way to
convince people because like oh the
progressives are always right in reality
the things they're implementing are
things from a long time ago that we
defeated
they're trying to rewind the clock on
freedom of speech
they're trying to rewind the clock on
racial segregation and they're getting
it
these people are outright reactionaries
who are trying to revert the system back
to the way it used to be because they
don't like the world we're in now that's
like double speak at its finest
progressivism that's what they do wow
the anti-fascists
and they go around beating people the
worst
part for that i've been thinking about a
lot
is that there's white moms that are
pushing
all this white men bad stuff online and
in the ballot box and it's just like
how what kind of culture and society
has moms that are doing these things
that are against their own children's
self-interest
or their own children's interests did
you see that emily ratajkowski
article for vogue where she's like i had
a friend who
was pregnant and she would look her
sleeping husband with disgust
saying there was nothing worse than a
peacefully sleeping white man in
patriarchy or something
oh my god and she was shocked that she
was bringing another white man into the
world
she cried yeah she cried and then she
later finally learned that she could
love her husband again
that is psychopath i'm trying to like
put myself in the position of a kid that
had what i had to hear that it would
have messed me up
so bad i thought i was just inherently a
problem
but that's all that the kids are hearing
right now that's what they're hearing
with critical race theory it's what
they're hearing with these stupid sesame
street programs and all this
propaganda that's flooding all the time
i mean you're having
white supremacy they're talking about
how like shooting
mass shootings or white supremacy when
it's mostly not white people
or that they're the ones attacking
asians
especially not white people mass
shootings are mostly white people
no i looked it up no look up the there's
a website that has the actual photos of
every single one from 2020.
the thing you're probably not counting
gang gang shootings
i just looked up the hard numbers for
shootings of four people or more
and it's like 66 white and like 22
black then they're not counting gang
shootings
there's some websites that don't count
them ah
all right shameless girlfriend says
first super chat absolutely love the
members only jack murphy content
cross smack openness is the most og
video on the tube
hoping for a shout out to steve cronin
early victim of youtube censorship and
true libertarian
crossmak openness was my first youtube
video
it's on my crossmak channel which was my
old my old email address and uh thank
you
for that i love it's real man freedom
thoughts says tim you've been talking a
lot about how the far left likes guns
that's definitely true but for how long
i think once they gain power they'd
strip them on another note you should
make some
tim cast logo stickers for cars perhaps
and you're probably right 100
once they gain power it depends the
actual
libertarian left pro gun will always be
pro gun and want to be hippies on a farm
with their guns and say leave us alone
we share in the fruits of our labor and
that's how it works
there's like a famous commune as a
hundred people and they mind their own
business
that doesn't scale up you can't make a
330 million government based on left
libertarianism sorry doesn't make sense
right libertarianism does because
capitalism is a structure by which
people can associate and form
you know an economy and then you have
the authoritarian left which is the
natural progression of the libertarian
left when they realize they can't
actually scale up their world
so then they become they are pro-gun and
then once they realize the only way to
maintain their system at scale is to
oppress people than they do there you go
all right the breeze says i don't know
the breeze job application remember when
you said you would read people's
application if they sent you fifty
dollars
no that was a joke wow here's a hundred
dollars so read it twice love you guys
uh well we will just search the gmail
for the breeze we'll see what we can
find
love all right let's see we got a couple
more here
e y says what is it sun say
i don't know what that is sunsei is uh
sun jan's
son he was a chinese warlord
from the wu province southeast china
sun say you run the the well he's not
speaking
uh chinese or whatever he's saying his
son say and then there's like i don't
know
no no different sensei
julie simone says thanks for bringing
cassandra back i get her passion for
west virginia i recently relocated from
ca to florida and feel the same
the level of personal respect for people
in florida is so refreshing after seven
years in california
awake not woke hi ian hi
there you go yeah i that's awesome
congratulations on getting out of there
i lived in california for a decade and i
yeah me too would never want to go back
goosey goo says idea for merch
don't tread on me but with baby chickens
instead of snake also hello cassandra
keep it the good
fight uh your friend goose that'd be
great little chicks
don't tread on me one of them says i
think it should be a goose
like attacking somebody that'd be
awesome yeah cause like gooses are nuts
when i when i yeah they're crazy
i can't remember the name of the park in
california echo park no no
no the one the one that's off of uh
wilshere close to
um east over there yeah yeah it's east
it's named after a soldier right
is it macarthur grant park no what is
macarthur yeah i think it's
park there's a bunch of crazy geese and
they are massive
and they harass you they go ah they
chase after you're like get out of here
and they'll like they'll peck at you and
like give me food
they charge you yeah i'm terrified of
birds except for chickens
they can deal with chickens we probably
killed off all the geese that could fly
because those things are nasty
and they could fly at you they're all
food oh you
sonny james as i literally watched a
reuters article edited like three times
the unvaccinated fear exclusion they
think they edited the title i swear the
original i watched says those on the
green passport are told what they can
and cannot do
i saved it before our rt reuters edited
you can go to archive.is and drop a link
and it'll clone the website archiving it
for basically ever and that's one thing
you can do if you're trying to track
these changes
z mcknight says i am also from the from
south side richmond
the city isn't growing and that's why i
left the leadership isn't good
in the river city that's that's a bomber
man
when these cities are falling apart
because you know you get bad leadership
because people you know many people
aren't paying attention
bad leadership comes in destroys a city
good people leave the city keeps falling
in a downward spiral it's a brain drain
i love
studying history for that reason like
civilizations are so transient there's
never been one that's lasted more than i
don't know a couple thousand years that
we know of
well they like will break apart and then
reform under similar names or the same
groups and it's like
i'll put myself in the mind of an
athenian looking at the beautiful
towers and and structures and thinking
this can this is the greatest that's
ever come
and it will never end because it's so
great and then it would just
get wrecked by a by external military by
a plague by a
earthquake like none of this is is
forever all right
last super chat the most important path
of resilience says
geese are essentially cobra chickens yes
and there it is
my friends thanks all uh thank you all
so much for hanging out make sure you
smash that like button because it really
does help if you're listening on itunes
or spotify leave us a good review
because that especially helps us out
you can follow me on social media at
timcast and my other youtube channels
are
youtube.comtimcastanyoutube.comcastnews
the show is live monday through friday
at 8pm so we will be back tomorrow
make sure you come make sure you come
and hang out and again share the show if
you like it cassandra you want to shout
anything out
um yeah i'm on parlor at cassandra i'm
on
telegram gab twitter you name it if you
want to
come yell at me or be angry or at
cassandra rules
or casper at cassandra rules on twitter
and on
gab i believe and on parlor it's just
cassandra but yeah
come say hi do
conspiracies with cassandra i like it uh
hey guys well thank you for everything
i'm ian crossland and you can follow me
in crossland.net
and bounce around all my social networks
from there all right
i am sour patch lids on twitter and real
sour patch lids on instagram where i do
my little
nightly show after where i talk about
what we talked about on the show
we are going to have a very special
members only exclusive coming up at
timcast.com in just about an hour so
make sure you go there become a member
if you would like to watch it but we got
a massive library that we've been
accumulating of all these different
people
so uh become a member support the show
and we'll see you all there
you